Tim Ferriss: KevKev, good to see you, man.
Kevin Rose: TimTim.
Tim Ferriss: Look at this.
Kevin Rose: In the flesh.
Tim Ferriss: In the flesh like grownups.
Kevin Rose: I know. Cheers.
Tim Ferriss: Sitting at a table in Austin.
Kevin Rose: Cheers, man.
Tim Ferriss: Look at this.
Kevin Rose: We're together.
Love it. Happy holidays.
Tim Ferriss: Happy Holidays.
Happy early New Year's, I suppose.
Kevin Rose: Was I supposed to shoot that?
Tim Ferriss: No.
Kevin Rose: Sip it. This is
quite good, that's sipping.
Tim Ferriss: This is sipping?
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, so this is
something that I've had on previous Random Shows,
but I don't think I've talked about it too much.
This is Lalo Tequila and Lalo Tequila,
full disclosure, it's my first and only
alcohol-related investment. I was first introduced
to this at a fantastic restaurant here in Austin
called Suerte. Excellent restaurant and —
Kevin Rose: I feel like you've talked
about this place before.
Tim Ferriss: It's great.
Kevin Rose: Maybe I should go there tonight.
Tim Ferriss: An excellent restaurant.
Kevin Rose: Is it hard to get in or no?
Tim Ferriss: Not too bad and there is
typically some walk-in available,
they reserve some space for walk-ins.
Kevin Rose: Sweet.
Tim Ferriss: And I went there for
the first time with Chase Jarvis.
Kevin Rose: Love Chase.
Tim Ferriss: You know Chase.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: And I had not seen Chase in
ages. He was coming in from out of town
wanted to do something Tex-Mexy, ended up at
Suerte and we wanted to have tequila because
we both both liked tequila, asked "what the
server most recommended" and he recommended
something I'd never heard of this Lalo and
I ended up really liking it, both of us.
Bought a bottle turns out that the namesake,
so Lalo is the grandson of Don Julio.
Kevin Rose: Oh, crazy.
Tim Ferriss: And this is
additive-free. It is matured in the plant instead
of in barrels. So it's a blanco, only blanco,
they don't sell anything non-blanco, and
they harvest from more mature plants.
So for a lot of the larger scale operations,
they harvest, one could argue prematurely,
and then they try to add a little razzle
dazzle with additives and the way that
they use the barrels and instead of doing
that, they're letting the plant do the work.
So this particular tequila for me at least,
is a very clean drink and I know this is a
topic du jour, of course, alcohol, no alcohol.
I certainly find a place for it and then about
six months, nine months later, a year later, out
of the blue a friend of mine reached out who does
a lot of CPGs. So consumer packaged goods stuff.
He's a genius when it comes to both operating and
investing, he's one of the best I've ever seen
and he said, "I'm not sure if you've ever heard
of this particular brand, but would you have
any interest in looking at Lalo?" I was like,
"Yes, I would, because I drink it all the
time." And that's how it came together.
Kevin Rose: That was going to be my question
for you, because I feel like so many of us
have had something that we've used in life and
said, "Gosh, I wish I was an investor here."
Have you done that with multiple companies?
Has there been something where you've said,
"This is so great, I have to invest?"
And then if so, what is your strategy
to get to that point where you can become
friends with a founder, talk about a round.
Tim Ferriss: You are better at doing
this than I am. You're one of the best
I've seen back when Twitter was usable,
sorry, but I remember Twitter and you've
used pretty much every channel available.
You're very generous and sincere. When you
find something you love, you share it.
Kevin Rose: Add value first.
Tim Ferriss: Yes.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: You are able to get the
attention of founders, historically.
I've seen you do this over and over again,
and often I'll do that. So these days for me,
if I find something, and I will sometimes look
at either my credit card statement or the stuff
I use the most and run down the list to see
if there's anything I might want to invest in,
for instance, and there are a few that
got away. There are a bunch that got away.
Like 1Password, I should have —
Kevin Rose: Oh, my God.
Tim Ferriss: And I knew the guys and they
ended up raising money maybe a year or two ago.
Kevin Rose: Like gajillion
dollars. It was massive.
Tim Ferriss: They're great guys and I'm like, "Oh,
if I had just..." And I didn't want to because
it didn't feel right, but if I had pushed just a
little bit more, maybe could have done something.
There were many stories like that that I could
tell but these days I would say I try to be
helpful. So I will take something and if it's
good, I'm like, "Look, even if I don't end up
being involved with the company, I want to help
them out. The product's fantastic.” So I might
put it in the newsletter. I might mention
it on the podcast. Do something like that.
Kevin Rose: Yeah you hear these stories every
once in a while. I remember when Facebook was
getting off the ground, Zuck wanted a
mural painted, do you know this story?
Tim Ferriss: I do, but you should tell it anyway.
Kevin Rose: The artist actually at that time said,
"Don't pay me in cash, pay me in stock," and
that's oftentimes a very good strategy where
you say, "Hey, I might not have the
capital to go invest in this thing,
but I have a skill and that skill is somehow
going to be useful to this company. If I can
make friends with them, then at some point
it's like, let's share the upside together."
Tim Ferriss: Totally.
Kevin Rose: And you don't
have to ask for a big massive percentage,
but you can say, "Hey, is there some options
available that I can have?" And that can work.
I mean for that guy, I think it turned him
into a billionaire or something like that.
Tim Ferriss: It turned into so much money.
Kevin Rose: At least several
hundred million dollars.
Tim Ferriss: David Choe, who's fascinating. .
He has done some incredible and hilarious things.
He's a very funny guy, very, very creative.
Kevin Rose: I don't know him but I've
heard that story so many times.
Tim Ferriss: He had a podcast called,
I think it was DVDA, Double Vag Double Anal with
Asa Akira, who's a porn star and it may have all
been taken down, but he is a polymath. He's
an incredible artist, incredible actor, also.
Kevin Rose: That could have been
the name of your show. No one
tried to come up with names for your show?
Tim Ferriss: Instead of TimTim TalkTalk?
Kevin Rose: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: You know, it was a close
runner up. We all have to make decisions.
I saw a shirt side note, well, I've had
one sip of tequila and here we go already.
I saw a shirt at a climbing gym yesterday,
which said "No solutions, only
trade-offs," and I was like,
that is actually pretty interesting to sit with.
But on the advising front, because that's really
what we're talking about, right? Where can people
learn more about that? Because I used to point
people, and maybe this is still a good reference,
it's a little dated, but Venture Hacks used to
have a bunch on advisors and super advisors.
This is worth unpacking a little bit for folks.
So if you look at, for instance, my track
record, the vast majority of my lifetime
earnings and startups have actually come from
advising, and that's not to say that it's easy,
that's not to say that times haven't changed,
because certainly times have changed since 2008,
2009, 2010, but if you have a skill or you have
a network or you have a platform, there are times
when it will be appealing for both you and for
a startup to have some type of trade for equity.
Sacca used to be fantastic at this before he
became the Chris Sacca and in marquee lights
that we know and love today and taught me
a lot about this, but you might look for,
let's just say I don't know how the landscape
has changed, you could probably speak to this,
but say 0.25 percent, right?
Kevin Rose: So it's early.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, like a quarter point.
Kevin Rose: It means you've seen
the company pretty early.
Tim Ferriss: Super early. And the
way that that's de-risked for the company, or one
way that can be de-risked, is that it vests over
a course of, say, two years.
Kevin Rose: Right.
Tim Ferriss: So every quarter, a percentage of
that basically becomes yours and the company
can cancel at any time and that allows them in
a sense to kind of try before they fully buy,
they get to see what results you can deliver.
Any other thoughts on folks, or?
Kevin Rose: Yeah, I mean I think —
Tim Ferriss: Thoughts on folks? Jesus.
Kevin Rose: No. We're one sip in.
Tim Ferriss: Well, this is related to caffeine,
which we're going to come back to at some point.
Kevin Rose: So —
Kevin Rose: I think it's important to remember
that every company that's out there, a private
company, when they're forming and putting
together their cap table, like their list of
investors, employees, all of that, they put
together something called an options pool,
which is a percentage of the company that
is used to incentivize those employees to
work there. So when you join a company,
you get X number of options and you earn
them over, say, typically three to four years.
A part of that, most founders will set aside for
advisors, and so these are people that are not
compensated with money, but rather just stock.
So in my mind, what I always do when I'm forming
a new company is I say "Okay, I'm going to take
one percent and I'm going to carve that into
10 roles and then I'm going to go out there
and find the 10 most impactful people that I can
possibly find to help me change the outcome of
this company." And you offer them in a role and
you say "Hey, no fancy strings attached." So I
never say "To be an advisor, you have to tweet X
number of times." Like, screw that. You want it
to come from a place of authenticity and so —
Tim Ferriss: And you're often doing this with
people you know —
Kevin Rose: Right.
Tim Ferriss: Presumably, right?
Kevin Rose: Or you could find someone that
you're just like, this is a really good match.
There's an AI company that I've been working
with and they needed someone that had a very
specific expertise in a very small subset of
a type of AI and they found an advisor and they
didn't know this person, but they reached out.
It never starts with, "Hey, we want to
offer you an advisory role." It's a coffee,
it's a hangout, it's a dinner, it's let's
get to know each other. And it's like, "Hey,
you might be helpful" and sometimes they'll say,
"No, actually, you can hire me as a contractor."
Or it's a mixture of both. They can say, "Hey,
we'll bring you on as a contractor for three
months and we'll give you an advisory role."
So there's no perfect science here, but just
expect to get some fraction of one percent of a
company as an advisor and your hope is that this
turns into a 100, 200, 500 million dollar company
and that becomes a very lucrative outcome for you.
Tim Ferriss: I would imagine part of the
reason that you're comfortable not having a
laundry list of deliverables is because their
advisor equity vests over a period of time.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, if that's over a period
of time, you can cancel it any time,
so if you're three months in and you're like
"Ah, this person's not doing anything," you can
just cancel it and no hard feelings, they get a
little small percentage of that and that's fine.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: I would say
that it's best in my mind not to overcomplicate
things, especially with celebrities. Celebrities
don't want to have some type of crazy, 20-page
document they have to run by their agent and
they have to go through with their attorneys and
they have to figure out "Oh, I'm going to have
to show up at this event." Like, screw all that.
If you work with a celebrity and you find someone,
you happen to know someone and they want to
be an advisor, say, "No strings attached. Oh,
by the way, we're doing this party
in two months, you can come or not."
Oftentimes that actually frees them up to
be like, "I don't feel like I'm being used
as a pawn here. Sure, I'll show up for a half
hour or 45 minutes" and that's a win for you.
You want them to speak from the heart
when they're talking about a product.
Tim Ferriss: And I think you would agree
that time kills deals, right? Some deals
do not get better with time.
Kevin Rose: Yes, exactly.
Tim Ferriss: Especially if you're dealing with
someone who has an entourage or a phalanx of
lawyers, managers, agents, et cetera, you want
it to be an easy yes. Make it an easy yes,
Kevin Rose: A hundred percent.
So I'll give you an example.
Back in the day when I launched Moonbirds, that
PFP project, the NFT project that I launched,
I talked to a handful of people and some people
that I knew quite well that were very famous
celebrities. There's one NBA player that is
a Hall of Famer that I gifted a Moonbird to
and I said "Hey, listen..." He's like, "I'm Web3
curious. I want to learn more about Web3" and it's
Ginóbili, like, you know him?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, huge.
Kevin Rose: So I gave him one and I said —
Tim Ferriss: Sweetheart of a guy, too.
Kevin Rose: He's a super nice guy, and I
said to him, I said, "Listen, you don't have
to tweet about it. This isn't a pay for play
thing. I would never want to do that. If for
some reason down the road you think it's really
cool and you want to say something, you can."
And he never tweeted about it, but that's
fine, you know what I mean? He just wasn't
vibing with it, didn't feel that it was going
in the right direction or whatever it may be
and same thing for Jimmy Fallon. Jimmy was super
kind, super nice, and he created a little parody
account for his Moonbirds and was tweeting
from it and he was figuring it out because
he wanted to learn Web3 wallets, he set up
his own wallet, he nested his own Moonbirds,
meaning he interacted with smart contracts and
dolls and it was because he was curious on the
tech side and there was no money exchanged.
It wasn't about that. So that's the
way I like to do these types of deals.
Tim Ferriss: And you tell me if this resonates
with you. I would also think in terms of whether
you're building a company or an advisor, who would
I like to work with on multiple companies?
Because I've seen, for instance, in many of
the cases where I've been an advisor, assuming
you do a decent slash good job, a lot of these
people, if they're good, are going to be serial
entrepreneurs and then you end up just advising,
advising, advising and they have their X-Men
squad that they pull in to most startups.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: That seems to me to be pretty common.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, I think there's certain
domain experts when you think about just
strategies around different parts of your
business where you say "Gosh, I would always
want this person in my corner if I'm going
to go launch a consumer internet product."
And so you go back to those people or if you
don't know, a great example is I'm relaunching my
podcast in January and one of the things that I
just have been out of loop on is a TikTok strategy
and I just really found a great company that had
been recommended and had worked with multiple
top 20 kind of podcasts on their TikTok strategy
because that's a hole that's missing, right?
So I'm going to go out, I ask 10 friends,
"Who's the best of the best at this?" And then try
and hone in on that person or people and then get
them to work on your behalf.
In this particular case,
I'm paying them for it, but that's fine.
Tim Ferriss: I think twerking is the answer.
Kevin Rose: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Like coordinated dances —
Kevin Rose: Twerking.
Tim Ferriss: And twerking,
you might have a little —
Kevin Rose: That's what
you do for your advisory service?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, a little case of werewolf buns.
I don't know if that's a plus or minus on TikTok.
January.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, January.
Tim Ferriss: Let's talk about January.
We're coming up on the new year.
How are you thinking about New
Year's resolutions, that type of thing?
Kevin Rose: Yeah, so we do this every year.
Tim Ferriss: We do.
Kevin Rose: I don't even want to go revisit
our list because I'm sure they're horrible.
Tim Ferriss: What do you think your hit
rate is on your previous list?
You had it written down. Do you
have your last list? Can you look at it?
I don't have it in front of me right now.
I would say that over the years I've
become better. My hit rate is higher.
Kevin Rose: 50 percent?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I would say it's 50 percent.
Kevin Rose: That's about me too.
Tim Ferriss: I'd say it's probably
50 percent, which hey, if that were start-up
investing man, you'd be best of the best, right?
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: But you
also don't want to set your resolutions
like "Brush my teeth three times a week."
You don't want to set the bar so
low just for checking the box.
Kevin Rose: Right?
Tim Ferriss: So I would
say it's 50 percent, maybe a bit more than 50
percent. I think this year they're simple enough
that I could actually get to a hundred percent.
Kevin Rose: Yes, that's exactly what I did. So
this year for me, it's about less, but make sure I
can try to get to 75 to a hundred percent of them.
So mine are really straightforward. Last
year I went one month without drinking.
This year my therapist has told me,
she's awesome, and she's like "Oh,
you made it a month?" She's like, "Oh, cool,
cool. Congrats. Everybody does that." And she's
like a little bit of a hard ass and I kind
of like that about her and she's like "No,
go three months." She's like "That's when the real
benefits start to show up is at three months."
And I'm like, "I mean, you could have said two,"
but she's at three. I'm going to go three months
without drinking. That's a big one for me. Daily
meditations, obviously, have been a big part
of my life. I'm going to continue that trend.
We can talk about Henry Shukman's new app too,
which is going to be a big part of that.
The Zen Master that I study under is finally
launching a new meditation app coming in
January called The Way and very excited
to help him with that app in terms of on
the product side and just usability side,
obviously he's doing all the content. I'm not
involved in it. I'm just an investor in it, but —
Tim Ferriss: Not involved in the content?
Kevin Rose: Not involved in content, right.
Yeah, I'm not a Zen Master.
Tim Ferriss: But you've
studied very seriously with Henry —
Kevin Rose: Yeah for a few years now.
Tim Ferriss: You introduced
us. He's been on this podcast —
Kevin Rose: Twice now.
Tim Ferriss: Twice,
and they're very strong episodes. So
I encourage people to check those out.
What makes The Way different?
Kevin Rose: So the one thing about as an investor,
so I'm a part-time VC, I had this other NFT and
art thing that I'm working on as well as a VC over
at True, we are looking for novel ideas, things
that haven't been done before and the meditation
app market is just completely saturated.
Tim Ferriss: Saturated?
Kevin Rose: Who would want to build an app in that
space? I mean, Calm's dominating, Headspace is
dominating, you know Waking Up, fantastic app for
more on the depth side, I would say Sam probably
brings together the strongest group of teachers,
I would say is a portfolio of meditation teachers.
Tim Ferriss: Like a university of meditation?
Kevin Rose: Yeah, exactly.
So Henry, his approach is, you know, If you go
into any of these other meditation apps, it's like
a meditation for sleep, a meditation for anxiety,
and meditation for this three-minute meditation,
two-minute meditation, 30-second meditation,
you know it's all these different — Henry's
very humble, but he's one of only, I think,
three fully accredited Zen masters in his
lineage of Zen in the United States and he
is bringing Zen, a flavor of Zen mixed in
with some other types of meditation and his
goal is simple. It's The Way, it's one path.
There's no choose your own adventure, it's like —
Tim Ferriss: It's not The Ways.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, it's not The Ways, right.
You can't branch off and do a body scan over
here and then come back for a sleep meditation
or a sleep story, it's none of that. It is a
singular path and his goal is to lead you to some
type of awakening moment sometime in the future.
So it's for those that are like "Okay, I've tried
the other meditation apps. I want to go deep. I
want to get really serious about this." So I can't
tell you when it's going to launch. They're in
beta right now. I can tell you that thewayapp.com
is going to be the place where you can put in
your email address and I'll let you know when.
You know what we can do for your show notes,
let's put a beta link, I think you can have up
to a thousand testers. Let's put it in your show
notes and get a bunch of people testing it out.
Tim Ferriss: Lovely. Yeah, we'll put
it at tim.blog/podcast real quick.
Kevin Rose: And you put a little
bit of cash in too, which is great.
Tim Ferriss: I did, which was going
to be what I was going to say next, this
is my first investment in a meditation app
and my first investment in any type
of consumer app in a while, in fact,
and that's based on my interactions —
Kevin Rose: Since Evernote.
Tim Ferriss: Y'know, which wasn't, that wasn't
a bad thing, It didn't turn into the thousand x,
10,000 x return, that I would like —
Kevin Rose: I've got to tell you they
turned it around. It's a good product again.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it is a good product. I
still use it, believe it or not —
Kevin Rose: Dude, this is actually
on my list anyway, we'll get into that
but yeah, finish your thought. Sorry.
Tim Ferriss: Well, I was just going to
say that I learned so much about product.
I learned so much about startups. I learned so
much about scaling, what to do, what not to do,
through my experience with that company where I
was an advisor because I didn't have the capital
early on to really build out a large portfolio
with cash alone, and I was able to request,
this is not a small thing for me. I was able
to make requests of product changes directly.
Kevin Rose: It's amazing,
that lifeline to the CEO.
Tim Ferriss: Lifeline to the CEO and
to the product team for me selfishly,
if I'm using an app every day that makes
a difference to my quality of life.
So I do not regret it. And part of your calculus,
if you're going to be involved with early stage
has to be, I think, the assumption that the
vast majority are not going to return what
you hope they're going to return.
Kevin Rose: Nine out of 10 fail.
Tim Ferriss: That's just part of a power law
distribution. Great book, by the way. Power Law.
So New Year's resolutions. What else do you
have and do you have a date? I'm just going to
hold your feet to the fire a little bit for your
three months. Have you decided on a start date?
Kevin Rose: Oh, so I'm going to invite
you to this, my birthday's in February
and you're invited. I got really lucky
to get to know the artist Sohn, S-O-H-N.
Do you know Sohn at all?
Tim Ferriss: No.
Kevin Rose: Have you listened to his stuff?
Tim Ferriss: I don't.
Kevin Rose: Oh, so good. So Sohn has become
a nice friend and he agreed to come play my
birthday party for 30 people.
Tim Ferriss: Amazing.
Kevin Rose: And so he's going to fly out, he's in
Spain right now, he's going to fly out and play,
and I've got to have a couple drinks there.
We're going to have a little bartender.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that would be,
you'd be failing before you started.
Kevin Rose: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: If your
first day were the day before your birthday.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, so I'm — after my birthday
is when I'm going to kick this off, so that'll be
good. But yeah, so really quickly to hit on mine.
So no drinks for three months, daily
meditation, no-brainer, I want to organize
my brain in digital form and so this is what's
really interesting in the last three months,
multiple notetaking apps have enabled AI and
what they're doing now is they're saying,
"Screw knowing where your notes are,
ask questions of your corpus of data."
So it's changing into a world where you can
just enter all the data, enter all of Tim's
brain into someplace and say "Hey, what was that
one note I had that one time when I was at that
Mexican restaurant and I think it was about cat
beds?" And it will literally serve you up that
note based on the AI and its crawling abilities.
And I think that's just fascinating. So Notion
has added that, there are three, they call them
second brain notetaking apps that are really for
that I'm considering. I'm still working through
all of them to see which one I like the best.
My candidates are Notion, Craft is amazing.
Craft is a really beautiful notetaking app. It's
a little bit more about here's the current day,
start taking notes, and then you can interconnect
the notes and do all kinds of fun things there.
Tim Ferriss: Is it spelled like the
dictionary word, or spelled like Kraft cheese?
Kevin Rose: Yes. C-R-A-F-T. Yeah, Craft. Obsidian
is another one. Have you heard of Obsidian?
Tim Ferriss: I've heard of it
or maybe I just like the name.
Kevin Rose: It's more like graph-based,
interconnected notes, all these backlinks tying
together thoughts and ideas. My Brain, you've seen
these cloud mappings of interconnected notes.
Tim Ferriss: Notetaking apps and services
also are a very crowded market.
Kevin Rose: Very crowded and
Capacities is the last one I'm looking at. I'm
leaning towards Craft. I think that's probably
going to be my go-to. It won app of the year
last year on iOS, and it's pretty fantastic
and I will say in that list, and still
actually I think the largest market share,
barely bidding out Notion, is Evernote, still.
And so I installed Evernote, the latest version.
I'm like, "This is actually a lot better."
I thought for a minute there it was going
to go under because it traded hands a little
bit, there was a little bit of drama there.
Tim Ferriss: It got overly
diversified, overextended.
Kevin Rose: Yeah but it is quite good.
They've revamped the app and it is nice.
So that and launching my podcast. And so
just keeping it simple, launching The Kevin
Rose Show. Yeah, I'll give it a one-second plug,
which is kevinrose.com. If you want to sign up,
I'll let you know when it launches, but
I've got some great guests lined up for
that show and taking it seriously, building
out a real studio, doing it professionally,
professional editors, the whole thing.
So it's going to be great.
Tim Ferriss: It is going to be
great. I can't wait to see —
Kevin Rose: I want to keep
it simple though this year.
Tim Ferriss: — what the roster looks like.
Kevin Rose: Not 10 things,
but just like three or four. What are yours?
Tim Ferriss: Mine are, and then I'm going to
come back. Don't worry, folks. It's not going to
consume the whole show. But I want to ask you a
question about AI, so I'll preload that into
your head, which is where do you think people
will compromise their privacy because of really
compelling convenience where they might regret it,
where they might click in providing
access, where later they'll be like, "Oh,
I really shouldn't have done that?" So that's —
Kevin Rose: I have two quick answers for that.
Tim Ferriss: Go for it.
Kevin Rose: One I think is going to
be photos. Don't ever click "Yes" to all-photo
access, especially if you've got dick pics.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
Kevin Rose: No, listen,
I went there because a buddy of mine just got
compromised last week. I kid you not. I kid you
not. So this is a true story. I'm not going to say
who. I swear to you, Tim, this is a true story.
My buddy got SIM-swapped. Somebody took over his
iCloud account and he's got a very, and my wife
knows this so I can say this freely, he's got a
very beautiful wife and he's a good-looking dude.
He’s a solid B, you know, kind
of like us, B minus, whatever,
and he's got pictures of his wife on his iCloud
and she's like, he's traveling a lot and she's
sending little, little hoo hoo, you know?
Tim Ferriss: Little naughty, naughty.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, and I'm like, I'm like, "Dude,
are you sending a little [whistle] back?" Because
those are the ones, no one's going to complain
about your wife getting leaked online. It's like,
"Are your pics going to get out there online?"
And it was a really stressful few days for him.
Tim Ferriss: I am sure, honestly, not to judge
anyone who's fond of shooting around dick pics.
I don't understand how anyone ends up in
that position. I'm just like, don't do it.
Kevin Rose: No, don't do it.
Tim Ferriss: There are certain commandments,
"Thou shalt not send dick pics." The downside
is so much higher than any possible upside.
Kevin Rose: Right.
Tim Ferriss: Plus, I mean, look,
maybe I'm biased. I'm just like I don't think I
have the Shrek of penises, but it's like I don't
understand what the appeal is also.
Kevin Rose: Well,
that's because you don't like penises.
Tim Ferriss: I'm not, yeah, I don't have a,
I guess, a collage of schwanzes made into a
piece of artwork on my wall. So maybe that's
it. Maybe I'm just, that's based on the team.
Kevin Rose: I mean for some people that's
the way they flirt remotely and
things like that and it's not me.
I don't do that either, but I think I am
actually doing a full episode on my podcast —
Tim Ferriss: On the dick pics?
Kevin Rose: On the dick pics,
no on locking down specifically iCloud. I
think it is the scariest place for hackers
to gain access to because they get your iMessage
messages and they also get your photos as well.
Tim Ferriss: Any quick tips for
folks, just a sort of teaser?
Kevin Rose: Yeah. Here's a quick teaser. Number
one thing you can do is that, so you want to hear
the crazy that happened to him.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, no.
Kevin Rose: This'll blow your mind.
Tim Ferriss: God,
here we can 10 X my paranoia. Here we go.
Kevin Rose: It actually wasn't a SIM-swap.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Kevin Rose: So what happened is that Apple, as
you know, if you forget your password, they have
something called iForgot, which is like you can go
there and say, "I forgot my password," and it says
"Okay, well do you have another device that you
can confirm?" "No, I don't have another device."
“Okay, well, what's your backup phone number?”
So you can reset that password with the backup
phone number that you put into the system. That
all makes sense, right? A SIM-swap, somebody
steals your phone number and they get access
to it, and then that's how you get compromised.
Their SIM-swaps are getting harder to do because
some of the big providers have caught on and
they've just tried to prevent that from happening,
ask you more questions, all of that nature.
Well, someone called in on his behalf to,
let's just say —, because it was —. You might
want to bleep that out if they’re you’re sponsor
at some point. But they called in, they
faked like it was him, and they didn't
ask for a SIM-swap.What they asked for, they
said, "Hey, can you forward the phone number
just for an hour to this other number? Because
I need it forwarded." So normally this would —
Tim Ferriss: So it was
straight social engineering?
Kevin Rose: No, but — straight social engineering
— but listen to this. Normally a forward wouldn't
work because a text message doesn't get forwarded,
only calls do. But you can go into Apple and
you can say "I have auditory problems, I can't
hear, can you call me with the security code?"
So they did a quick forward, they
called, it didn't go to his phone,
it went to the hacker's phone. Apple read the
security code to them via audio. They put it in,
compromised reset, it changed his phone number,
compromise, download all of his data, and then
tried to blackmail him to get his data back.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, my God. Okay. So in terms
of teasers for?
Kevin Rose: Yes,
teaser number one thing to do is that you
want a cell phone provider where there is
not a phone number to call and it's
really, truly, securely locked down.
Your best provider for that in the United
States is Google Fi and what you do is you
don't set it up with your Google account.
You create a brand new Gmail account that
no one knows, TimTimsecure8537@gmail.com —
Tim Ferriss: Dammit, you just doxxed me so hard.
Kevin Rose: Exactly, and then you
two-factor the auth the crap out of that,
turn on Google's advanced protection there.
Then you sign up for a Google Fi account,
which is a brand new phone number. Then you tell
Apple that is your backup phone number, because
Apple can still service your main number, but
only use that backup number to reset passwords.
So there's no possible way anyone would know that
backup number. So it's a whole thing. There's more
steps to it than that. You get hardware keys
involved. Like Google's Titan Key, which is the
most hardcore of the USBC keys hardware keys,
uses one of their Titan chips, which is legit.
It's a whole thing, but it's scary.
Tim Ferriss: It's terrifying.
Kevin Rose: Yep.
Tim Ferriss: Time for me to
double down. My phone has been acting funny
recently. It's making me spooked a bit.
Kevin Rose: It scares the crap out of me.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. It's like my phone has
been acting a little funny and I'm like, weird.
Kevin Rose: Well, you know what sucks too is
I've been going to WhatsApp more and doing that
in seven days, delete all my messages because
honestly, there are, tell me if you feel
this way, I know you feel this way because
we have these conversations on text.
There are things that you say with
your friends that you're just like,
"If anyone read this out of context,
I would seem like the most insert whatever."
Tim Ferriss: Oh, every person who uses group
threads, if you are remotely interesting —
Kevin Rose: Or if
you're funny.
Tim Ferriss: At all.
Kevin Rose: If you're funny.
Tim Ferriss: And funny, you're all fucked.
If anything were made public everybody's screwed.
Kevin Rose: Exactly. The number of jokes I've made
that are not something I would not want the world
to see, but are all in good fun and just amongst
friends, it's like in the thousands, right? And
if that shit got online, I would deny it all. I
didn't write that AI did.
Tim Ferriss: The AI did.
Kevin Rose: But yeah, it's tough, so anyway,
this is actually really good tequila.
Tim Ferriss: It's really smooth. So
on the AI front, real brief and then —
Kevin Rose: Oh, we said photos was
the one part. You asked "What were the
places where AI might compromise your data?"
Tim Ferriss: Yes. So that's the first one.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, so I think photos would be the
main thing and then the second one would be just
this idea of these notetaking apps. Because if
you're journaling, for me, I have a fantastic
therapist, I journal all of that, right? So things
like Obsidian, the reason I'm drawn to that one in
particular is its local only. So it doesn't sync
to the cloud and when it does, it uses a local
encrypted key so not even they can read your data.
I trust Notion, but if someone were to compromise
their key on their end in theory, even though the
data is encrypted at rest, meaning when it's not
being used, it's encrypted on their hard drives,
it is still a potential vulnerability there.
But at the end of the day, if someone
really wants to read my therapy note,
it's like whatever. We live in a world where you
can just be like, "Ah, someone made that up."
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, there's a whole new
world of plausible deniability with AI
and there's a whole new world of exploits, wild.
On the AI side. For people who might be curious,
I've actually, not on my personal notes, but we
have trained, or I should say rather Automattic,
which runs wordpress.com and I rely on their
enterprise side of things for all of my websites.
They have an AI feature and they've trained this
AI on all of my transcripts. So if you want to ask
questions of 700 or so transcripts of The Tim
Ferriss Show, you can do that and the results,
in a lot of cases, are surprisingly good.
Kevin Rose: There's several startups working
on this. I saw one that actually indexed
your show and if you ask a question of it,
will return the clip in which you said
the answer to it, which is amazing.
Tim Ferriss: I've seen this.
Kevin Rose: I was thinking the other day about a
great startup that I don't have the time to build
would be a podcast app that, imagine this world,
and tell me if this is interesting to you, so
it trains on all of your data. I'm listening
to The Tim Ferriss Show. I'm halfway through an
episode and you mentioned something that I don't
understand or I'm just not familiar with, right?
I will just say "ayahuasca" for something random,
and I hit pause and I hit the Tim AI button.
Now it's trained on your voice so it
can respond in your voice.
I say "Tim, what is ayahuasca,
actually, before we continue the show?"
And you respond. You say "Well, ayahuasca is this,
and I talked about it in episode number
12, blah blah, blah and also number 27,
here's a clip of me saying this," and then you
can rejoin the stream of the podcast and continue.
So it's almost like you show up as a coach
mid-podcast for any questions I have about
that show so I can pick your brain and also
as applied to your books so I could go into
your entire corpus of books that I have
and ask questions of that data as well.
That has to be the future, right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that's interesting.
Kevin Rose: How do you feel
about that as a content creator,
does that make you a little uneasy?
Tim Ferriss: It doesn't make me uneasy
on a content level because I operate from a place
of abundance with my stuff because my stuff is so
dense, right? It's not dense necessarily in a
bad way, but it's like I could talk about the
content of, say, one of my books for hours
on dozens of podcasts and not come close to
exhausting even 20 percent of that book. So
I'm very forthcoming with that. The one flag
I would say that I have for that particular
example is that if it's my voice and so on,
and this is going to come up a lot with AI, what
is the indemnity? What does liability look like?
Kevin Rose: Right, right.
Tim Ferriss: If someone uses
an AI and they're like, "Well, this
Tim AI told me that I should do A, B,
and C, or that I should or could X, Y, and Z."
Kevin Rose: Right. It's the 0.0001, you hope,
percent chance they get it wrong. And
then as applied to something dangerous,
right? Because that could be —
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Kevin Rose: Telling you from The 4-Hour
Chef how to make runny eggs the wrong way,
who cares? But telling you to take the wrong
supplement dosage is a whole another can of worms.
Tim Ferriss: There's dangerous, and then
there's just opportunity for scammers.
Kevin Rose: Right. Well, that's
happening regardless, dude.
Tim Ferriss: Well, it is.
Kevin Rose: Tim's going to be
calling me all the time, pitching me a new book.
Tim Ferriss: Well, but not just on the AI social
engineering side, but for instance, we
don't have to spend a lot of time on this,
but there are people called career plaintiffs out
there. Unfortunately, I know what this is. But
for instance, there will be a law firm. What they
do is they file class action lawsuits based on a
couple. Barbara and Bob Jones are the couple that
they work with all the time. And they're like,
"Hey, Barbara and Bob, Subway sandwiches is
selling 11 and a half inch subs, but they're
calling them foot-long. Go buy two of them and
then complain with us and we'll file this thing
and we'll give you 10 percent of the upside."
And I think that some of these AI models will
provide a nice, juicy bite of the apple.
Kevin Rose: That was actually a real lawsuit
by the way that you're mentioning.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I know.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
But we won't get into the details of why I know
that. But God, the US, man, some of these things,
it's just astonishing that the rules provide
for some of these creatures to exist and profit.
Coming back to New Year's resolutions, we had a
nice big boomerang on that. Mine are, I would say
simple, not necessarily easy, as is true with a
lot of things. The first is minimalist delegation.
And what that means to me is delegating the
why and the who, but not necessarily the
how. So I think my predisposition is to be very
detailed when I delegate various types of tasks
or projects. In other words, what I would like to
do more of is, "Here is, at the simplest level,
five words of what I want to do, figure it out.
And you can handle all the specifics. You should
know that we should have at least three bids if
we're putting something out that's expensive, dot,
dot, dot, dot, dot." But to really take my hands
off the wheel in terms of over-prescribing the
details, which I have a tendency to do because my
mind is very detail-focused. I'm very meticulous,
but I have found that, more often than not, I
can point to examples of where I'm providing too
much step-by-step detail. And also people
who receive that in some cases feel like
they're being micromanaged.
Kevin Rose: Not only that,
they're not building the muscle.
Tim Ferriss: Exactly, the confidence.
Kevin Rose: Because they need to understand,
the only way they can build that muscle around
who you are and what you want is by
making mistakes and you saying, "Hey,
I would've done it this way a little bit
differently because of X, Y, and Z," and
then they learn from that mistake versus you just
prescribing. And it saves you a shit-ton of time.
Tim Ferriss: It saves a ton of time. So what I'm
experimenting with, and I've already started doing
this, and I think I've made a lot of progress, is
say less. Say less and be available for questions,
but otherwise make it clear that
there's a certain degree of wiggle
room and space for errors that is okay.
Kevin Rose: So when your admin walks in,
you say, "Sandwich." If a meatball
sandwich shows up, you throw it against
the wall and say, "Wrong fucking sandwich."
Tim Ferriss: That would be one way to handle
it. And I remember there was, I want to say, a
blog post a while ago that was written by either
Ben Casnocha or Reid Hoffman, but Ben Casnocha
used to be the, let's just call it aide-de-camp
or chief of staff for Reid Hoffman. And what Reid
had said to Ben was something along the lines,
and I remember this because I had to look it up —
this would be a chance for me to interrogate the
Reid AI — "What do you mean by blah, blah, blah?"
He said, "In the service," I'm paraphrasing here,
but, "In the service of speed, I'm willing to
accept 10 percent foot faults." And I was like,
"Foot faults? What does that mean?"
And I think it's a tennis reference,
which is like when you step over the line when
you're serving and you get called for a fault,
but in the service of speed, basically, the way
I interpret that is you can get 10 percent wrong.
Ideally, it's not really expensive,
catastrophic stuff, but I'm willing to accept
a 10 percent error rate in the service of speed.
So I'm trying to think about it along those lines.
Because there are so many things that are either
reversible or inexpensive where it doesn't really
matter. It doesn't really matter. You're better
off making the wrong decision, and then right
decision and doing both of those quickly because
you course correct. Then taking a ton of time to
deliberate in your mind when oftentimes you don't
even have complete information, you don't know.
Kevin Rose: But also, imagine you get that down
to five percent, the extra effort required. What
is that doing to you as a burden versus just
letting go a little bit and letting those faults
happen? And it's got to be a little bit freeing.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, totally. Question for you,
because I thought you recommended
at some point this book to me,
and I have two or three friends who have
recommended it since, The Surrender Experiment.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Are you still a fan?
Kevin Rose: Michael Singer?
Tim Ferriss: Yes.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, I'm still a fan, I think.
Tim Ferriss: Could you say a little bit about
it? I don't know if we've ever
talked about it on the podcast.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, I haven't read it for probably
two and a half or so years now. But Michael Singer
is, I would say just a general kind of, I don't
know how to put it other than just like, I don't
want to say spiritual guru or more just kind
of like a salt-of-the-earth type guy that has
figured out that surrender is kind of the ultimate
freedom. This idea that you can just release and
let go, puts you more in the present moment than
pretty much anything else. And the whole book is
around how when stuff comes in, it doesn't hit
you. It doesn't hit and stick. So to hit and stick
and marinate and fester is not surrendering.
It's letting the energy build and bring you
down oftentimes. And the book is framed around
this idea that the more you can let go, the more
freedom there is, the more happiness there is. And
as Henry Shukman put it, the freedom comes from,
not the tight grip on reality, but the slow,
finger-by-finger letting go of that grip.
Tim Ferriss: And part of the appeal
for me, as it was described to me,
I have not read the book, but a very close
friend of mine is reading it right now.
Kevin Rose: He has a course,
by the way, that's fantastic.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Kevin Rose: It's on Sounds True.
It is a video course, and it is quite good.
Tim Ferriss: It's a video course?
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss:
Is it necessary to watch the video or is it —
Kevin Rose: He's a quirky personality and he's
great on video. He's just really funny.
Tim Ferriss: And it seems like that
book at least is his personal story, which
automatically makes it more engaging for me.
Kevin Rose: A hundred percent.
Tim Ferriss: All right. So yes,
letting go. So the minimalist delegation, and the
second point is actually related to that. That is
the, in a sense, letting go. Quick creative
collaborations is the second one. I only have
three things. It's minimalist delegation, quick
creative collaborations, and then physical reboot,
which is pretty straightforward to me.
Again, it's simple, but not always easy.
Kevin Rose: We've got to get into
my physical reboot here in a minute.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, we're going to talk about
it. So quick, creative collaborations. This is
an area where you have seen me actually kick the
tires quite a bit in the last year with COCKPUNCH,
which by the way, there's a ton coming with
that, which is going to be a big surprise
to a lot of people. But I have done enough.
Kevin Rose: Buy COCKPUNCH, I'm taking notes real
quick here. Buy NFTs, Tim Ferriss, COCKPUNCH.
Tim Ferriss: That's right.
Kevin Rose: Hashtag financial advice to the moon.
Tim Ferriss: No, not financial advice. Jesus,
that was AI talking. I didn't say that.
And in the process — using this NFT project
way back in the day, which is, when it
launched in December of 2022, I guess,
as a vehicle through which to do creative
experiments, emergent long fiction, that was
kind of the whole point. And I have walked that.
I've walked the talk in the sense that since then,
and a lot of this has been invisible, but it will
soon be visible. I've done creative sprints in
say, upstate New York with some of the top D&D
and Magic the Gathering artists, I should say.
People who have done amazing iconic work for those
brands doing character design and concept art.
Kevin Rose: How's that felt to you?
Tim Ferriss: It was so much fun. It
was so much fun. And I have had this narrative
that I'm a better IC, individual contributor.
I'm better as a solo operator. And that in
some sense, I think because I've heard from
some publishers and so on that I'm a bit of
a problem author because I'm very, very, very
unwilling to compromise quality. I am unwilling
to compromise quality, and I'm very meticulous.
And so if somebody's not on that same page, I'm a
problem. And so I developed this narrative that I
was just prickly and difficult and didn't —
Kevin Rose: How much of that do you think
is true? Have you ever done a 360 review?
Tim Ferriss: I have done a 360 review. The
feedback doesn't usually fit, I wouldn't say it
supports that narrative. And in this particular
case, gather all these folks, had some writers as
well, which I thought was going to be harder than
the art side because I can step back and say, "You
are all much better at art than I am. But I have
an identity as a writer." And it was great. I had
two writers, three artists, and had an absolute
blast. The output was spectacular, which I haven't
made public yet, and that emboldened me to do more
and more experiments. And so I can't talk too much
about it right now, but I am actually working on
my first book project in seven years, eight years.
And I'm doing it with a collaborator, which I
thought I would never do in a million years.
Kevin Rose: Okay. Wait, you've got to give us
a little more, fiction, nonfiction, fantasy.
Tim Ferriss: Nonfiction. This is OG TF style.
Kevin Rose: Five-hour.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, five-hour, but very dense, hyper
tactical, not dense, very rich. In other words,
it's not a bunch of fluff. I'm not turning a blog
post into a 300-page book. You're going to want —
Kevin Rose: Can you tell us what it is?
Tim Ferriss: I can't. I can't.
Kevin Rose: Can you give me a genre?
Tim Ferriss: I can't really give
you a genre of what I would —
Kevin Rose: It's not a cooking book again?
Tim Ferriss: It's not. I think everybody got their
fill of cooking with that. I'm very proud of that
book, but holy shit, that almost killed me. No,
I'm not doing that again. Also, not making the
foolish decision to say to myself, "You know
what I should do? What would be fun is for me to
do 30 to 50 percent of my own photography for a
700-page cookbook." Don't do that.
Kevin Rose: Not archery.
Tim Ferriss: If you're not a photographer,
don't do that. It is so much work. Oh,
my God, I really respect the photographers
out there. I underestimated that one.
Kevin Rose: But you dodged the archery
question. It is an archery book.
Tim Ferriss: It's not an archery book. I'm
planning on doing more archery that is part
of the physical reboot. But the quick, creative
collaborations this book is going to be about,
I would say, how to find the essential and ignore
the trivial. That's the very broad strokes. But I
am collaborating on writing, which I thought
I would never do. It is going better than I
ever possibly could have imagined. And
it has opened the floodgates for me to
think about what other collaborations I could
pursue. Screenplays, animation, television,
who knows? But I've realized that if I
am paired with someone who really gives
a shit about quality and cares about being
really proud of their work, I'm totally fine.
I can collaborate really well with those people.
They just have to have really high standards.
And I'm excited to do more of that. So the
screenplay side and the TV and animation is
particularly interesting to me. So I'm becoming
more adept with a format like a screenplay and
the format itself has intimidated me. And I
feel like I just need to be locked in a room
with someone really good for two weeks and be
like, "You cannot leave until you have something
to ship." It can be a rough draft, but it has to
be pretty much ready. And I think that's doable.
So the quick creative collaborations
is something that I'll be doing more
of. And then last on the physical reboot, I
have been such a piglet in the last month.
Kevin Rose: You're looking thicc.
Tim Ferriss: That's T-H-I-C-C, folks.
Kevin Rose: Looking thicc.
Tim Ferriss: And I'm not in terrible shape,
but I am planning on continuing to be a little
piggy for Christmas and the holidays because I'm
going to be home with family. And I love butter
cookies. I love gingerbread cookies. This is kind
of like you not committing to your three months
before your birthday. That would be stupid. So
I'm going to be spending January, February in
really intense outdoor training and skiing and
ski touring and so on. So I'm not worried about
burning off what I'm accumulating because that's
going to happen, especially at high altitude.
Kevin Rose: I'm going to try and visit you,
by the way.
Tim Ferriss: Awesome.
Kevin Rose: January.
Tim Ferriss: That would be fantastic. So the
physical reboot is up there, and I'm optimistic
about that because on the internal level, meaning
biomarkers and so on, almost every biomarker
is the best that it's been in like a decade.
Kevin Rose: Wow.
Tim Ferriss: After the last year.
Kevin Rose: That is not me. That sounds amazing.
Tim Ferriss: And some of that has been certainly
physical practice exercise. A
lot of that has been dietary
Kevin Rose: How's your Apo B?
Tim Ferriss: The best it's ever been?
Kevin Rose: How low?
Tim Ferriss: I can't recall offhand.
Kevin Rose: Okay. 20s to 30s?
Tim Ferriss: It's within the
aggressive Attia target range.
Kevin Rose: AST, ALT, fine?
Tim Ferriss: Oh, yeah. Those are always fine.
Kevin Rose: Homocysteine always good?
Tim Ferriss: Homocysteine is always fine.
Kevin Rose: Okay.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. My liver enzymes and —
Kevin Rose: What have been your issues then?
Tim Ferriss: What was that?
Kevin Rose: What are your issues?
What did you correct in your blood work?
Tim Ferriss: There are a couple of
things that I've corrected. So I have
historically high uric acid levels.
Kevin Rose: But you're on an allopurinol then?
Tim Ferriss: I'm not on an allopurinol because
I had a reaction to it.
Kevin Rose: Oh, dang.
Tim Ferriss: It can be very dangerous.
Kevin Rose: Yes, it can.
Tim Ferriss: So I'm on
something called Uloric, which is fine.
Kevin Rose: It's actually better,
a cleaner drug, I think, Attia says.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. There's a bunch of
debate around it because there were some
smaller studies that were arguably poorly
designed that did some type of head-to-head,
and it got poo-pooed. But Uloric for me is
a good option. Not medical advice. Talk
to your fucking doctor, please. I don't
play one on the internet. In addition to that —
Kevin Rose: That's from your meat, by the way. You
know that? That's your meat intake.
Tim Ferriss: No, it's not.
Kevin Rose: Are you sure?
Tim Ferriss: Yes, I'm sure.
Kevin Rose: Because typically uric acid, they used
to call it the king's disease, right? It causes
gout and it was from wine and meat and fats.
Tim Ferriss: It's considered a disease of
[inaudible]. So the wine is more interesting.
Kevin Rose: Okay.
Tim Ferriss: So yes, people associate it with, if
I'm not mistaken, purines, and it gets associated,
therefore with protein intake also. But there's a
blog post. It's easy to forget. I have a thousand
plus blog posts, which actually bridged the
books to the podcast. It's easy to forget
that connective tissue with a thousand
plus blog posts. One of them is called
something like "The [Missing] Chapter from
Good Calories, Bad Calories." Good Calories,
Bad Calories book, great book.
Kevin Rose: Daniel Taubes.
Tim Ferriss: Gary Taubes.
Kevin Rose: Gary Taubes
Tim Ferriss: And one of the chapters
that ended up on the cutting room
floor was about fructose and how —
Kevin Rose: Which Attia is anti.
Tim Ferriss: Right, which
also ties into uric acid.
Kevin Rose: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: So what I have seen in myself,
at least, it doesn't matter if I am carnivore
diet, vegan, fasting, whatever dietary liver I
try to pull, uric acid is high. It just does not
matter. And that's also hereditary. This runs in
my family. The other constellation of issues
are all cardiac, like, lipid profile related.
Also hereditary. Dietary intervention, with
the exception of one thing that I'll mention.
Kevin Rose: Are you on a statin?
Tim Ferriss: I'm not on a statin.
Kevin Rose: Okay. Well, your Apo B is fine.
Tim Ferriss: Just to be clear. So there are
different reasons that your lipid profile
can be out of whack. In my particular case,
and I might be able to put something
in the show notes as a resource,
there are sophisticated labs or companies that
will run labs that fine slice a lot of this.
Kevin Rose: Boston Heart?
Tim Ferriss: I think it's
Boston Heart. And then you need someone
to interpret the tea leaves, obviously,
in which case you need a very competent doctor.
In my case, I'm a cholesterol hyper absorber. More
accurately, I'm a sterile hyper absorber, which
means I can also absorb a lot of steriles from,
say, plant matter, which is why automatically if
you reduce meat or eliminate meat, it doesn't mean
that your cardiac and lipid profile will improve.
And you actually see a lot of folks for which it
goes the opposite direction because they end
up consuming a lot more refined carbohydrates.
Their fasting glucose goes up and they end
up with a whole host of issues, in some cases
associated with fructose. Like, "Oh, agave nectar,
brilliant. Well, maybe not so brilliant." And for
that reason, in my case, I'm taking ezetimibe,
actually, I'm taking something called NEXLIZET,
which is absurdly expensive. Welcome to
the United States in this case. But it's
a combination of ezetimibe and something called
bempedoic acid. Ezetimibe, very well researched,
pretty well understood. Bempedoic acid, a newer
player on the scene, but very interesting.
And the combination of those two, plus the Uloric,
are what got a number of biomarkers of concern,
not crazy. And I've done not only the usual
cardiac calcium scores, which are helpful,
but incomplete in a lot of ways. I've also
done angiograms, which you do not want to
do willy-nilly all the time, but I wanted to
see if there were any precursor to any issues.
So far so good. In my particular case, those
things, plus reducing saturated fat intake.
Kevin Rose: Dude, saturated fat
makes a difference. It's the killer.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it makes a difference.
Kevin Rose: It screws up all my numbers.
Tim Ferriss: It makes a difference. So in my
case, it would be a bad idea for me to hit the
MCT smoothies. Right?
Kevin Rose: Right.
Tim Ferriss: So Bulletproof
coffee, bad idea for me.
Kevin Rose: Also, the MCT, I don't
know if it does it to you, but it —
Tim Ferriss: Disaster pants.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Risk goes up.
Kevin Rose: Yeah. Yeah. Risk goes up by about 10x.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. If you're —
Kevin Rose: You run to the
bathroom with the MCT oil.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Yeah. If you
are thinking to yourself, "In 2024, I want to shit
my pants more often," I would recommend a coffee —
Kevin Rose: If you're constipated.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Creatine, double espresso,
and MCT oil, problem solved.
Kevin Rose: Oh, my god.
Tim Ferriss: Don't ask me how I know that.
But you can guess. Don't have that right
before you're driving to the airport for your
international flight, also, pro-tip. So the
minimalist delegation, fast delegation, embracing
reversible or low cost possible mistakes,
quick creative collaborations, and then physical
reboot. And honestly, with the physical reboot,
a lot of that is old news. The stuff that
works works. It's like kettlebell swings.
Kevin Rose: Zone two cardio.
Tim Ferriss: Ski touring, zone two,
which I'll get to very naturally with what
I'm going to be doing in terms of hiking and
ski touring and so on. Basic, basic basics, I
shouldn't say basics. The fundamentals are the
fundamentals for a reason. And just when in doubt,
return to fundamentals, it's like weight training
once a week, that is better than nothing. Once
a week. And then the zone two. But also for me,
it's like one or two sessions of very, very hard
technical Pilates to hit everything that I'm going
to miss anyway, like medial glute.
Kevin Rose: I'm getting back
Pilates in the new year, by the way.
Tim Ferriss: And that's about it. Do
less than you think you can do. If some of your
goals are around physical reboot or recomposition,
set the bar where you are sure you can clear it.
Kevin Rose: So I wanted to talk to you real quick
about, you mentioned the physical body
reboot. One of the things that all of my
physicians, not all, it sounds bougie to say,
all my physicians, my primary care physician —
Tim Ferriss: Tell us, President Obama.
Kevin Rose: — has been concerned about is,
I have slightly elevated blood pressure. And it's
not to the point where I should have it treated
with medicine, but there's breathing exercises
you can do. There's a device called RESPeRATE,
which Peter Attia recommends.
Tim Ferriss: I don't know it.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, it's fantastic. It hooks
around your chest. It's like a strap. And
then you put in some EarPods that are connected
to this device and it walks you through a series
of breathing exercises, and it's clinically
proven to lower your blood pressure. So Attia
recommends that as kind of first line defense
for slightly elevated blood pressure. There is
a device that is approved in the UK and the EU,
and it's called Aktiia. And it's a horrible name.
Tim Ferriss: What?
Kevin Rose: Aktiia,
not Attia. They're going to get a cease and
desist from Attia. Yeah. So it's A-K-T-I-I-A.
I'm wearing it on my wrist right now. So if
you're watching the video version, you can see
this thing is smaller than the smallest Fitbit.
It's super tiny. The battery life is five days.
It does every hour blood pressure monitoring. It's
clinically proven accurate. And Attia is testing
it right now in his lab with his folks there.
It is not approved in the US. So what I had to
do is, I bought it online — at first, I got a VPN,
I proxied into their website to make it look like
I was in the UK. And then I bought online, shipped
it to a friend in the UK, who sent it to me in the
States. I then created a fake iCloud account in
the UK with a fake email address and VPN to act
like I was in the UK on a separate phone that I
had not sent in, like one of my older iPhones. And
then I was able to get the app installed through
the UK app store because it's not available in the
US App store and got it to work.
So technically this is not
legal in the United States.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, contraband.
Kevin Rose: But I'm actually monitoring it
and the breathing exercises are helping.
A high salt intake combined with water is
huge. If you have a salty steak or anything,
I can notice, just remember when we first
got into CGMs, you were way before I was,
but in the continuous glucose monitors, you got
me into them. And you would be surprised because
you would sit there and you'd be like, "Oh,
banana doesn't do anything." And some people,
banana shoots you through the roof, right? Or rice
for me, oh, my God. Through the roof. I don't know
about you, but rice for me is a huge offender.
Tim Ferriss: Rice affects me less than it
affects you, but it affects a lot of folks. And
footnote, in a previous episode, we talked about —
Kevin Rose: The rice cooker.
Tim Ferriss: Which drains out the water.
Kevin Rose: Carbs.
Tim Ferriss: Which
dramatically reduces the glycemic response.
But back to our scheduled program.
Kevin Rose: We can link that in the show notes
as well. But yeah, so this for me has been like,
"Okay, I just had a salty meal. Now let me chug a
bunch of water along with that meal." And actually
I will notice a difference. I do not get into
those, what they call the high orange levels of
blood pressure just by my water consumption.
Tim Ferriss: Meaning you help or
hurt by drinking more water?
Kevin Rose: Yes, drinking water.
And there's evidence to back this up, but he's
had people on the podcast who have talked about
this. But anyway, it's another device that, I
hope, knock on wood, they've submitted to the
FDA, the hope is that we'll have this device
approved in the States here, I don't know,
next six months to a year. So we'll see.
Tim Ferriss: Very cool. Anything else on
the physical reboot side? The three months with
no booze I think is going to be, if you can do it,
no offense, it'll be a revelation, I think.
Kevin Rose: It's going to be amazing.
Speaking of it looks like you're not a
big fan of your own tequila. No. I just
noticed you're not really drinking any.
Tim Ferriss: Well, first of all, no.
Kevin Rose: If you don't like it —
you're just selling it, that's fine.
Tim Ferriss: It's also, we started recording a
3:00 p.m. so usually I'm not a 3:00 p.m. drinker,
but you know what?
Kevin Rose: I want
to be in bed by seven, so, okay.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, geez. Okay. Since we're
just checking back into the home anyway, where
they're going to put our socks on and put us to
bed. No problem. Yeah, yeah. All right.
Kevin Rose: Dude. Let's retire
at the same retirement home.
Tim Ferriss: That'd be so fun.
Kevin Rose: That'd be so much fun.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: I was about to say something bad.
Tim Ferriss: Cheers, man. It's nice to see you.
Kevin Rose: Cheers.
Tim Ferriss: So let's talk about —
Kevin Rose: Sorry. I was enjoying that.
Tim Ferriss: — taking breaks from stuff
because I have kind of a wild story, which I
don't think we've talked about at all. I have
a number of wild stories.
Kevin Rose: Oh, yeah,
I've got one big one for today.
Tim Ferriss: You have a big one
too. And I think these are going to be
interrelated in a sense. So I'll piggyback
half of it after what I believe you're going
to share. But I took a month off of caffeine,
anything caffeinated.
Kevin Rose: Wow.
Tim Ferriss: Which was the first —
Kevin Rose: Cold turkey?
Tim Ferriss: Cold turkey, which was the first
time I've done that, probably I would have to
imagine since I was what? 16. It's been forever.
Kevin Rose: Let me ask you a question here. Why
would you do that cold turkey? Why not just
do like, "Oh, I have a cup of coffee today,
and then maybe a quarter cup a few days
later." Why go — this is like the extreme Tim.
Tim Ferriss: Well, it's —
Kevin Rose: Did you get headaches?
You must have gotten something.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I got headaches,
but it was during a period where I could —
Kevin Rose: But you had Vicodin before.
Tim Ferriss: No, I didn't use Vicodin. I
knew that I could accept the headaches,
and I had a period of time where there really
was a low cost, where professionally I was taking
three to four weeks off the grid and I knew that
I had a grace period where I could sustain it.
So I did effectively, no caffeine, no alcohol,
and I suppose the most important other item —
Kevin Rose: No sex.
Tim Ferriss: No sex and ejaculation,
which we can talk about that, but that's pretty
easy. The harder one is I did nothing sweet. So
not just containing sugar, but nothing sweet. So
anything that has an artificial sweetener was out.
Kevin Rose: Would you consider this tequila sweet?
Tim Ferriss: I would not consider this tequila
sweet. And there is a bit of
subjectivity for a lot of it.
Kevin Rose: It says sweet notes to it. It's not —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it's got some floral notes
to it. But by the kind of letter of the law, I
wouldn't consider this subjectively to be sweet.
But for instance, any kind of juice, out, any
type of sweetener, of course, out, let's just say
different types of plantains, if they are sweet
to the taste, they're out. Sweet potatoes out.
Kevin Rose: Is that hard for
you? That's not hard for me.
Tim Ferriss: It doesn't seem hard. But let's just
extend this. Almost every toothpaste has sorbitol
or some kind of crap in it that is a sweetener.
Kevin Rose: So no brushing
your teeth for two weeks.
Tim Ferriss: I brush my teeth with
sodium bicarb, just baking soda.
Kevin Rose: Just straight up.
Tim Ferriss: I brush my teeth with that for a
handful of weeks. And what you also realize is in
the US or in this case, when I went to Korea, if
you ask people if A, B, or C has any added sugar,
there is sugar or some type of sweetener in
almost everything that you come across. That
was interesting. It was challenging because
it severely limited what I could eat. But
the caffeine was an amazing experience. Now, I
alluded to this a little bit earlier. I'm back
on the sauce over the last week, week and
a half, which I regret, number one. And I'm
paying a lot for, there are costs.
Kevin Rose: In terms of sleep?
Tim Ferriss: Let me explain. So let me back
up and I'll just give you the punchline.
Kevin Rose: Well, tell us why you did this to
begin with, because you didn't mention that,
it wasn't a New Year's resolution. Why?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. So the reason that I
did — it started because I was in South America
doing a bunch of weird stuff and there were
restrictions, and then I just extended everything.
Kevin Rose: By weird stuff, psychedelic stuff?
Tim Ferriss: Yes, psychedelics, which will
tie into a part of my strange story later.
But I hadn't done the type of training I was
doing in South America in probably five or six
years. And so I took restrictions very seriously.
I think that is important in my opinion. And then
I extended them all. And I wanted to see in part
because I met someone who said they had stopped
drinking anything caffeinated, cold turkey,
because they felt like a loser because they'd
become dependent on it. And they'd missed a
really important ski day, one of the first
days of the season. And they're a really good
skier. And they were with a group of people and
I believe they were the only person who skipped.
And that day they were just like, "No more." And
to this day, two years later, caffeine free.
Kevin Rose: Wait, wait, wait. I lost something
there. When I wake up in the morning and I have
a cup of coffee, I can go skiing. Why did they
miss skiing because they couldn't have coffee?
Tim Ferriss: Because they didn't have coffee that
morning and they were so tired.
Kevin Rose: Oh, I see.
Tim Ferriss: That they felt like they couldn't
do it. So they stayed on the ski lift,
instead of getting off, they just went
around and went straight back down.
Kevin Rose: That's amazing.
Tim Ferriss: And called
it a day. And to their credit —
Kevin Rose: They've got to be under
the weather or something if they
had to miss a day of skiing, there.
Tim Ferriss: But to their credit, they were
just like, "This is fucking loser behavior.
Enough." And they went to zero. And that caught
my attention because when you talk to someone, no
offense to anyone who fits in this category, but
let's just say if someone is a Mormon and they've
never had caffeine, that's not my life, right?
They've never had a hit of the sauce. Although
technically their workaround is Diet Coke —
Kevin Rose: You are the
furthest from a Mormon I know.
Tim Ferriss: — instead of coffee, but we're not
going to get into the weeds there. But if somebody
hasn't had a taste of the delicious poison.
Kevin Rose: Sweet, sweet nectar.
Tim Ferriss: There's so many things,
right? There's so many things like this
where it's like, okay, if you've had one
significant other and you've never been out
and about and sampled the buffet of the world,
we can't really have — it's very hard to have
an apples to apples talk about relationships.
It's a different situation. Same with caffeine.
But this person had been hitting the sauce for
decades, and then they got off. And that was
inspiring to me. Then I had this restriction
and I just extended it. And just to give
the punchline, my sleeping issues that
I've had for decades, every single one just
vanished. Best sleep of the last 20 years.
Woke up wide awake every morning after the
first, let's just call it week and a half,
had tons of energy and got a super high volume of
stuff done. And what I realized, and the part of
the reason to answer your meta question, why did
I do all of these things? I was curious what my
real baseline was. What does real baseline look
like? What is Tim, untouched, unaffected by all
these various supplements? That's another thing.
I took a month off of all supplements. I only
took my prescription meds like the Uloric
and so on. I got rid of all supplements.
Kevin Rose: No Deca or testosterone or anything.
Tim Ferriss: No Deca, no nothing.
Kevin Rose: Okay.
Tim Ferriss: And I was very curious to reacquaint
myself with what the sort of pure baseline Tim
is. And turns out baseline Tim does really well.
Kevin Rose: Why go back then? Why?
Tim Ferriss: Well —
Kevin Rose: You got hung over.
Tim Ferriss: No, I didn't get hung
over. I didn't get hung over coffee.
Kevin Rose: Because it's good after
a hangover, a little bit of Le juice.
Tim Ferriss: Also, before I went to South America,
I listened to an audiobook, which was called
or is called The Easy Way to Quit Caffeine.
And that is an extension of a brand that
started with smoking. I think it's The Easy
Way to Quit Smoking. And I know literally
multiple people who've listened to this,
had their last cigarette, and they're done
and they stop. So it's a little hokey,
but that made an impact on me as well.
Kevin Rose: I'll do that for January. I'm
write that down on my list. January. No caffeine.
Tim Ferriss: Now that I know I can do it, I'm
definitely going to do it again. The reason that
I got back on it, and I'll actually add just a
little bit of color. The first is that there were
days without caffeine where I would say to myself,
"I'm tired. I really want a cappuccino." But I
realized, because I interrogated it, I was like,
"Well, I'm not allowed to have a cappuccino. Am I
really tired?" And I came to the conclusion that,
no, I wasn't actually tired, I just
wasn't fucking wired. You see what I mean?
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: My normal had become multiple
coffees in the morning and God knows what else.
Kevin Rose: Right.
Tim Ferriss: So I had taken as my baseline
a default, wired sounds too negative,
but stimulated state. And when that was removed,
the story that I conjured was, "I'm tired." But
when I was unable to have the cappuccino and I
went on to record a podcast, podcast turns out
great. I'm like, "Okay, let me revisit this."
I wasn't tired, I was just calm. Interesting.
Kevin Rose: Crazy.
Tim Ferriss: Interesting. And why did I get
back on coffee? Coffee for me, I've realized, is
probably alcohol for a lot of folks. And there's
sometimes, I'm not going to lie. Look, let's be
honest here. There are times when it's like I
want to take the edge off, "Sure, have a drink."
But more often, because I don't drink that much,
I use coffee as a security blanket when my
life gets hit with something unpredictable
or unpredicted and things seem a little out
of control or I'm not sure how I'm going to
make it through something, walk into the coffee
shop in the morning and having that coffee is,
it's a life raft of consistency. We saw this
during COVID, right? Where people would line up at
Starbucks for three hours to get a coffee because
it was like the one semblance of normality.
Kevin Rose: It's like a ritual and
there's also a high to it, so it's like —
Tim Ferriss: There's also a high.
Kevin Rose: — yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So even though I realize
intellectually that it's counterproductive.
When I am feeling as I have been for a host
of reasons that I won't bore people with,
but just gone through a pretty challenging
week or two, my response to feeling a little
anxious is to want coffee, even though
it increases anxiety physiologically.
Kevin Rose: This is one thing actually,
we've known each other for a long time,
I don't know the answer to this. I don't know
that I've seen you do this. Are you an afternoon
coffee guy at all? I don't know that, I've
seen you do matte maybe a little bit later.
Tim Ferriss: I typically do not have coffee in the
afternoons. And I really try not to have caffeine
in the afternoons, which I violated this week. So
in the last two days, or I should say in the last,
let's just say in the past seven days I
have violated that. And what I've realized,
because I've run the N of one now, and there are a
bunch of different variables, so I realize this is
imprecise, it's not a perfect science. Is that I
can drink coffee and fall asleep, that's not the
problem. But it disrupts my sleep architecture.
Kevin Rose: Quality of sleep, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I wake up after three days, very
little time. Three days of drinking caffeine,
I wake up and I have circles
under my eyes, dark circles.
Kevin Rose: Are you quantifying this in the sense
of, are you wearing an Oura Ring? Do you have any
other data where you're looking at it?
Tim Ferriss: I'm not currently capturing
the data with an Oura Ring, but I have in the
past, I've seen what it looks like. So I know
that's the case. I'm falling asleep. My time in
bed, if we're just looking at a clock is fine,
but I'm waking up tired.
Kevin Rose: I hate that.
Tim Ferriss: And then what do
you want? You want another hit?
Kevin Rose: Of course.
Tim Ferriss: You want more of the sauce.
Kevin Rose: First thing, a little juice.
Tim Ferriss: And there's a lot to be
said for it. This is not to completely knock
coffee. I don't think, for the rest of my life,
I'm going to be caffeine free. But now I
have a better awareness of what my baseline
looks like, so I can return to that.
Kevin Rose: So let me tell you something
crazy. This was before I met Darya, so I'm
trying to go back in years now. So probably,
let's just call it 15 years ago, I
gave up coffee for about six months.
Tim Ferriss: Six months?
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: That's legit.
Kevin Rose: But I wasn't really that
addicted to it, I was having a cup every other
day or whatever. And I went back, I remember I was
living in San Francisco at the time and I went to
Ritual Coffee, which is a fantastic coffee place.
Tim Ferriss: Great place.
Kevin Rose: And I ordered a
tall single origin coffee and I drank the
whole thing. And I will tell you, when you
go six months without coffee and you have a
full cup of coffee, you feel high as a kite.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, super.
Kevin Rose: I was like 10x
what I feel today with a cup of coffee. Because
your body just, I mean it is a powerful drug when
you've gone without it for a while.
Tim Ferriss: Super powerful.
Kevin Rose: Do you have any sense of
how long it takes to get that back?
Have you done any research to —
Tim Ferriss: To get what back?
Kevin Rose: — an initial childhood
high of that first cup of coffee?
Tim Ferriss: I see. How long do you go
without before you get back to that?
Kevin Rose: Yeah, we can tell you like —
Tim Ferriss: I don't know. I don't know.
I will say on the opposite end, which
is what I thought you were asking. How
long does it take to develop a tolerance and
experience withdrawal symptoms? It is so fast.
Kevin Rose: Oh, so fast. One
day if you go without coffee —
Tim Ferriss: It's so fast.
Kevin Rose: — for serious coffee
drinkers will be headaches.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Well, I would say furthermore,
if you stop drinking coffee, and I'm using coffee
as a bit of scapegoat here, I love coffee. But
if you go without caffeine and then you get
back on caffeine and you're on it for two or
three days and then you stop again, my personal
experiences, you are going to feel withdrawal
symptoms. And that is unlike most other drugs. It
is a powerful, powerful, powerful drug. I'm not
recommending this, but hypothetically, if you were
to smoke cigarettes for a few days and then stop,
you're fine. No problem. You're not going to
have a headache the next day. But with caffeine,
it is an incredibly powerful drug. And I think
that's in part because it is often disrupting
sleep architecture. That's my vote, at least.
Kevin Rose: One question for you. One of the
things that I have yet to try that I've been
really curious about, is I know that there are
cultures, I can't remember, I'm going to screw
it up. I don't don't know if it's an Inca or I
can't remember exactly which culture it is from
Mexico that did high dose chocolate, almost like —
Tim Ferriss: Cacao?
Kevin Rose: — a cacao ceremony where they
drink this super purified cacao, insane amounts of
caffeine, and they reach these kinds of spiritual
states. Have you ever heard anything about that?
Tim Ferriss: I haven't read reports, but I know
that for instance, I want to say in some
places in Mexico, certainly in Guatemala,
you have cacao ceremonies.
Kevin Rose: I was invited
to one, one time, a cacao ceremony.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. I don't know the
historical record. I don't know how much of
these things were used a hundred years ago,
a thousand years ago. There are many new
practices that have created the narrative
of age-old use for a veneer of credibility
when in fact things were very different a
thousand years ago.
Kevin Rose: You
have to imagine cacao was a staple.
Tim Ferriss: Cacao has been around for a while.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So in the case of cacao, my
understanding is it contains theobromine, which in
and of itself is a fascinating word. So theobroma,
theo like theology, broma, food, food of the
gods. Theobromine, which is pharmacokinetically
very — meaning, just if you were look at the
graph of peak and half-life and so on, it's quite
different from caffeine, is my understanding.
Kevin Rose: There's actually the vasodilator of
the plant. What causes — because I know
CocoaVia, for example, are you familiar
with that supplement, CocoaVia?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it's a cacao
supplement from a large company, I believe.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, from Mars, actually.
Tim Ferriss: From Mars, yeah.
Kevin Rose: But the crazy thing is, I was
talking to Rhonda Patrick about this and she has
had one of her, I think it was her mother-in-law
or something like that, high blood pressure,
takes CocoaVia, drops it down because it's a
vasodilator and is a big fan of it as well. And
it's been shown cognitive improvements as well.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I'm not sure, it very well
could be the case. I mean, when you get — the
dose makes the poison, the dose also makes the
transcendence for a lot of different plants.
So in the case of cacao, I have experienced
higher, let's call it higher-dose cacao and you
can reach an altered state for sure. I'm going
to caveat what I'm about to say with the "Do
not ever do this" warning. But for instance,
there are plants that, at high enough doses,
are absolutely psychedelic, which I would never
recommend because you can die. Let me repeat
that. Fatal risks, so do not try this at home.
But tobacco as an instance, as an example,
has a very rich history in South America and
elsewhere, but especially in South America
where high doses of juice have been consumed.
Every mode of administration you can imagine
has been done and is very common down there.
There's a book by Johannes Wilbert, which is
titled along the lines of [Tobacco and Shamanism
in South America], it is very dense, it reads like
a PhD dissertation. But when you consume pretty
much through any route imaginable enough tobacco,
you can experience a psychedelic experience.
Kevin Rose: Oh, my God. Can I tell you a
story about this?
Tim Ferriss: Sure.
Kevin Rose: I've had this. So, I was in
San Francisco at the time, and they have,
this was, I call it a decade ago, they have a
bunch of chefs that are very experimental. I won't
name the chef, but it was a one Michelin star
chef that infused tobacco leaves into an alcohol.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, boy.
Kevin Rose: And you have to be insanely careful.
If you look up online, like you said, if you put
too many leaves in the infusion, you will have a
lethal overdose of nicotine that will kill you.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: And so this chef knew what they were
doing. I would never try this at home. They made
me a bourbon-infused tobacco cocktail.
And I was like, "This sounds interesting,
I'll give it a shot."
Tim Ferriss: Hope you
don't need to sleep anytime soon.
Kevin Rose: Dude. No, listen, I drank this one
drink and I'm having a good time getting a little
chatty and like, "Ooh, this is fun." And then,
dude, I get up to use the bathroom.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, boy.
Kevin Rose: And I swear to God, it
felt like my feet were sinking into
the ground as I was walking, or I was
walking down to the stumps of my knees,
like my legs were collapsing as I was walking.
Tim Ferriss: You're like, "Wait a minute."
Kevin Rose: And I was like — because I don't smoke
tobacco at all or anything like that. And it hit
me a ton of bricks and I'm like, "I am high as
shit." It is a very potent substance, especially
for non-smokers, you've got to be really careful.
Tim Ferriss: So coming full circle. So cacao,
powerful, fascinating plant, sacred in a number
of different cultures. Tobacco, be very careful,
folks. It is powerful and potentially lethal.
And then coming back to caffeine, it is the,
as I understand it, the world's most
commonly consumed psychoactive plant.
Kevin Rose: Via tea. Tea is the number one.
Tim Ferriss: Tea and coffee. And it has this
place, I love my cup of coffee. Trust me, I
had one this morning. And I think the exercise,
if you can do it, not everyone can, but of
rediscovering what your baseline is. What you
actually felt like when you were 12 or 15.
Kevin Rose: I'm actually writing
this down, because —
Tim Ferriss: It's so valuable. It is so
valuable because I now know what that feels like
and I know that I can return to it as an adult.
Kevin Rose: Yes. And that holds true to anything
that you're doing that, call it alcohol,
any substance that you've become dependent upon.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: It doesn't have to be just caffeine.
It can be anything that you've, that you almost
feel like you can't live without. Right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Sugar, carbs,
some activity, traveling.
Kevin Rose: Late night pizza.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, late night pizza. If
you're a road warrior and you just travel
all the time because you say yes to everything,
okay, what does it feel like to sit at home,
if such a thing exists for you? For one
month, what does that feel like? And if
a bunch of weird stuff comes up, maybe as Tara
Brach would say, "To one sage, only one question
matters. What are you unwilling to feel?"
Kevin Rose: Oh, my God, I have to have
her on the podcast. That is one
of my top guests I need to get.
Tim Ferriss: She's great. If you haven't
read it, folks, Radical Acceptance,
which DarDar, I owe DarDar thanks for.
So if you don't get the reference —
Kevin Rose: DarDar is my wife, Darya.
We call him TimTim, so we — the family.
Tim Ferriss: Which came about, actually, let's
give people a real look into the archives. So
TimTim came about because we were on a trip to
China to drink Pu-erh tea all over the place.
Kevin Rose: That's right.
Tim Ferriss: Which was one of the weirder
trips I've ever been on for a lot of reasons.
Kevin Rose: We were in the Yunnan province
together in the middle of nowhere.
Tim Ferriss: We had some very strange
experiences on that trip, drank a lot of
tea, had a motley crew of people with us
along for that ride. And there was another
Tim on the trip. So there was a question of,
"How do we keep the two of you separate?"
And you came up with, I believe, TimTim.
Kevin Rose: I mean, it was a —
Tim Ferriss: Collaborative decision.
Kevin Rose: Kind of real-time.
Tim Ferriss: That's how TimTim came about.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So Darya, who is a neuroscientist
by training, which is why I actually took
the book Radical Acceptance seriously,
because all due respect, I love Tara, loved this
book, and a huge impact on me. But the title gave
me an allergic reaction. I was like, "Oh, God,
another one of these." Sounds hand-wavy. Kumbaya.
Didgeridoo. Like, "Okay, I just can't do it."
But the fact that Darya, who has one of the
lowest tolerances for bullshit, hand-wavy stuff
that I know of, the fact that she said she gained
from it, gave me permission to dive into it,
which then had a really big impact on me. So,
coming back though, if you feel like you can't
live without X, that is often a great signal or
at least a prompt to ask yourself, what might
an experiment look like for two to four weeks
to go without X? Been super valuable for me.
Kevin Rose: That's awesome. I wrote it down. No
caffeine in January, I'm going, I'm serious.
Tim Ferriss: I might double
down and do it with you.
Kevin Rose: Let's do it.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Yeah. No caf.
Kevin Rose: All right, let's talk
about my experiments, shall we?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, let's do it.
I'm excited. I'm excited about this, because
I also don't know the details. I know that —
Kevin Rose: You saw the text messages.
Tim Ferriss: — I saw some of the text
messages and I was very curious.
Kevin Rose: Okay. So, I don't know
how to frame this. Let me start off at
the best I can. So, this is a big one.
Tim Ferriss: You're pregnant.
Kevin Rose: I'm pregnant. What was the
one where Arnold Schwarzenegger got pregnant,
what was that? I can't remember the name.
Tim Ferriss: I can't remember the
name. But yes, I know the movie.
Kevin Rose: But basically, I have
the same physique too. So basically,
for people that know me or don't quite know me,
I've done a bunch of stuff in terms of being
like an entrepreneur and an investor and these
different things. And one of the hats that I put
on a couple of years ago was dabbling in the
world of Web3. And Web3, for those untrained,
it's cryptocurrency, it is decentralized
internet, it is NFTs, it's art of the blockchain.
Tim Ferriss: It's ownership, right? If 1.0 is
read-only internet. 2.0 is read, write. Three
is actually owning a piece of what's on the plane.
Kevin Rose: So it's a very exciting frontier and
it's filled with a bunch of explorers
that I would say it's a small number of
people, call it probably, in terms of people
that are excited about digital art, call it
250,000 people or less. But it is a serious group
of people that are enabling a new canvas to take
form in front of us. And I believe in my heart
of hearts that for all of the bad press that we
see about NFTs and all the scams, and don't get
me wrong, there's tons of that shit, there is
something true about, if you had to close your
eyes and wake up in 20 years, will collectible
digital art be a thing? Of course it will. And the
blockchain is a perfect place to prove provenance,
to prove scarcity, there's a lot of advantages
there. Long story short, I launched something
called Moonbirds, which was a PFP project.
Tim Ferriss: I remember the text
I got on the day of that launch.
Kevin Rose: Oh, my God. So, we launched this
collectible NFT and it skyrocketed way beyond what
we had ever thought. So to give you all a sense,
from launch to one year in, over a billion
dollars has been traded in Moonbirds NFTs.
Tim Ferriss: That's so wild.
Kevin Rose: And I did not expect that.
I really didn't. But with that comes trading and I
have never lived the world of trading. I've grown
companies to quite some size, but never publicly,
I've never taken a company public. And when you
take a company public i.e, NASDAQ and New York
Stock Exchange, you deal with the ups and downs
and feedback from people that are now stakeholders
of that particular company. It's different. This
is an equity. Holding an NFT does not make you a
shareholder. It's very different. But they still
pay attention to what is the price of this NFT.
So, when the NFT goes up, times are good,
people are happy. And when it goes down, people
are not happy. I've had people truly hug me and
say they've paid off their house because they
sold one of my NFTs for $200,000 and they were
stoked. And it was like tears kind of hugging.
I've had people basically tear me apart saying,
"I am the other person on the other side of that
equation that bought that NFT for," let's call
it whatever, 50,000, 75,000, 10,000, doesn't
really matter, it's all relative to how much
that person has as an individual, "and how are you
going to fix this because NFTs are down and they
need to go up." Right? And some of it is on what
we build to try and build bigger and better things
for the ecosystem and try and hopefully prove
that we are a company here for the long term.
It has taken a serious emotional toll
on me as an individual. I've had many,
many sleepless nights. I've had anxiety like
I've never had before. I've had to work with
therapists and I've had to reach out to my primary
care physician and get anti-anxiety medicine,
which I've never had to do before. I have had some
dark moments with some, not dark like in suicide,
but dark as in, it's destroyed me because I've
always considered myself an honest person. I've
never been here to screw anyone over.
Tim Ferriss: You're also a very,
I consider you to be an empathic feeler.
Maybe the right word is you're a deep feeler.
Kevin Rose: I am a feeler. For sure. For sure.
Tim Ferriss: If something like that is sitting
with you, you take it very personally. And I
remember you had stomach issues for so long.
Kevin Rose: Yes. Oh, my God. IBS-related
issues. And so this year I've been treated
multiple times for these types of issues with
physicians, all kinds of things. They discovered,
the high blood pressure thing was discovered
because I have a brain aneurysm right now. It's
on the smaller side and they're watching it and
I'm fine. But those grow the more stress you're
under because the more blood pressure that builds
up, the larger the aneurysm can grow. And so,
as you can imagine, all these things hit
you at once. And so I felt overwhelmed.
I felt like I couldn't go to work. I felt like
I kind of just needed to reset. And Huberman,
who I love, who's been on my podcast, Andrew
Huberman is a top 10 podcast now. Oh, my God —
Tim Ferriss: He's killing it.
Kevin Rose: Killing it. Love that guy.
Tim Ferriss: He's doing such
an amazing job of executing.
Kevin Rose: I don't think I've seen anyone better
at doing monologues and the way that he can do
them about scientific topics. I mean just, if
you haven't subscribed to Huberman's podcast,
I mean it's along with Attia's, top
five medical podcasts to subscribe to,
along with Rhonda Patrick, they're all heroes.
Huberman did a couple-hour episode on ketamine
therapy. And ketamine therapy, it's used for PTSD,
it's used for severe depression and it's used for
anxiety. And it sounded really interesting. It
rewires neuropathways and Huberman's episode,
highly recommend, I'm not a scientist,
but he is. And he goes in-depth about
what it actually is doing on the brain.
And I always thought of ketamine clinics
as being these shady places. These places where
there are real people with real addictions that
they treat. If you're hooked on, say, everything
from amphetamines to any type of serious addiction
problems, they see these types of people and also
people that are about to kill themselves, really
suicidal. If you go to an emergency room right
now and you say, "I'm going to end my life in
the next 10 minutes," they will most likely treat
you with some type of ketamine to just get you out
of that state. It's a very common emergency room
like, a Hail Mary to get you back into a state
of just being, "Okay, I don't want to end my life
right now." And now we can work this out or take
you to an institution where you can get help. So
I was never there, but I got to the point where
I was like, "I need to do something dramatic
and different and I need to reboot because I
can't take the comments I'm getting on Twitter."
Tim Ferriss: Now, did you see the Huberman episode
organically, did someone send it to you?
Kevin Rose: Organically.
Tim Ferriss: Organically. You just came across it?
Kevin Rose: It just came across and I was like,
"Oh, I've always been interested in ketamine." I'd
heard about ketamine in a recreational setting.
And sadly, who was the Friends star?
Tim Ferriss: Matthew Perry.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, Matthew Perry had just, the
toxicology report came back and said that he
was on ketamine when he drowned. But we can
get into why that is in a minute. But in a —
Tim Ferriss: Let's focus on
your personal experience.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: And I'll just say also, ketamine
and jacuzzis or pools or water do not mix.
Kevin Rose: Oh, my God. Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: And there are multiple
fatalities. Don't mix those two things.
Kevin Rose: Well, when you go under
ketamine, you are literally sedating
yourself to where they can give you surgery.
Tim Ferriss: It's dissociative anesthesia.
Kevin Rose: Yeah. So what my doctor has told me
that, the ketamine doctor, she's an emergency
room doctor that did my treatments, is she said
to me that, "If you came..." She was a 10-year,
I think 10- or 15-years emergency room
doctor. And she goes, "If you came in and
you had dislocated your hip," she goes, "I would
inject, I would give you," What do they call
a bolus dose, is that what they call it?
Tim Ferriss: A bolus is — right. I mean,
they're giving you a lot at once.
Kevin Rose: A lot at once. They just
push it all in, right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: And she's like, "I would give you
that to about…" I can't remember the exact X,
but it was a multiple on which they give you
for therapy, "to put you under so I can get
that hip back into place, and then you wake up
feeling fine." Unfortunately, with Matthew Perry,
he took a dose that was equivalent of
subconscious fainting, falling asleep,
drowning type dose. And they said the toxicology
report, I read it, he had that level in him that
would've put him in that state of passing out.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Drugs and water
don't mix, folks.
Kevin Rose: Don't mix.
Tim Ferriss: Just don't mix those two.
Kevin Rose: Anyway, my point it wasn't the fault
of the ketamine, he was using it recreationally
versus under supervision of a professional, which
is what is needed. So, I found this clinic in
L.A. that they literally have the set and setting
right. So they're all about you come in, it's just
beautiful, comfortable, peaceful music, really
relaxing, reclining chairs. Eye mask, because
it's important to go inward. It's not about just
getting this therapy and looking around the room.
Music with drums and beautiful — sometimes I pick
my own playlist, I did a little bit more chanting.
You don't want lyrics or anything to distract
you. And they have you hooked up to a blood
pressure cuff that measures throughout the time,
a heart rate monitor, really professional
setting. It's called Golden Afternoon,
is the name of the clinic in L.A.
Tim Ferriss: It's an amazing name.
Kevin Rose: It's an amazing name. And the doctor
there she's a — gosh, I'm going to draw a blank
for where she — I think she was. Was she Penn? I
can't remember where she got her MD. But top-tier
school, emergency room doctor, as legit as
they come. So I felt really comfortable.
Because you know a lot of this is
about set and setting and comfort.
Tim Ferriss: And safety.
Kevin Rose: And safety, yeah. So I
went in there and I was like, "I'm going to give
this a shot, because Huberman convinced me that
this can help me with anxiety." And so I laid down
on this comfortable chair, turned on the heating,
they have a heating element in the chair, tilt
you back a little bit, put on my noise-canceling
headphones. They gave me an IV. An IV does sound
hardcore, but for people like you and me that
do IVs or do blood draws every other week, who
cares? I don't care about this shit, but it does
sound hardcore to most people. They gave me an IV
and I closed my eyes and I went to a place, man,
I went to a place. And it's a beautiful place.
And it made me, over multiple treatments, and I
did eight in total. And they normally do six for
depression, which is really interesting. Because
she said that, it's typically anxiety is harder to
treat than depression in her experience. And they
gave me eight in total and you do two per week.
And about halfway through, the best way I can
describe it is, imagine that life is a series of
crunches. And I say crunches like the ab workout.
Whereas nobody likes to work out their abs, right?
Because abs are like, "Ah, fucking ab day." Nobody
wants to do that. And I didn't realize it, but I
had had a 35-pound weight on my chest the entire
time I was doing ab workouts. And it took that
weight off and I had, and I still have, and it's
been weeks later, a bit of grace and lightness
to the way I'm carrying myself throughout life
that is just a peace that I haven't felt
since I was probably 10 or 12 years old.
Tim Ferriss: Were you interacting with anyone
in those sessions, or it was all internal?
Kevin Rose: No, it's all internal. So it's
headphones on, music, eye mask. The entire session
lasts for about an hour and a half. They have a
camera that's watching you. If anything comes up,
one time I had my music accidentally stop and
I raise my hand. They're in there within 30
seconds. They bring you hot tea when you're
done. They let you take your time to slowly
kind of come to. And then you can literally
walk out there and carry on with your day.
And the first session I was like, "Okay,
that's beautiful." Second session was a
little difficult. Because they caused it — they
say it kind of like, imagine it's loosening up
the plaque in your brain and rewiring circuits
and it's not always going to be easy. But by,
I remember the sixth session, I just walked
out there and Dr. Jenn came in and she goes,
"How are you?" And I said, "I could run a
marathon right now. I feel amazing. I feel
like a weight has been lifted off my chest. And
I just — this is such important work that you do,
such important work." Because it's not about
being — there's not an addiction to the substance,
I don't need to go back. Some people go back for
boosters depending on what they have. She told
me that some people that have depression, they'll
come back in every three months, every six months.
She said some people, she never sees again.
But it kind of takes the anxiety and pulls
it apart from your body so that you can see it
for what it is, which is silliness because life
is play. And when you realize life is play and
we're all here just trying to figure out our shit,
why are we taking it so seriously?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, there's a
lot that just does not matter.
Kevin Rose: It doesn't matter. We
can just chill, man, it doesn't really
matter. We have clean drinking water.
What the fuck are we complaining about?
Tim Ferriss: So the weight on the chest,
was that something that you can't put words
too that you just felt release or — and you
don't need to get into details, I'm
just curious. Or was there a content
to it where you're like, "Oh, interesting."
Kevin Rose: No, it wasn't content. Content
was beautiful. And I don't know if you've ever
experienced this, Tim with, I've never done
ayahuasca, although at some point I would love to
try it. But I opened my eyes and it was when the
mask is on and I was seeing things that were as
high of fidelity as what we see today, like right
now. Where you're like, "I am in a room right
now." And I felt very present, my dad's passed
away, I felt very present with a father source
there at times. I felt very connected. At one
point I saw the entire world and I saw how small
I was. And I was just like, it immediately gave
me this sense of just gratitude for that being
that little speck, but also at the same time,
not having to take and carry the burdens of
the world on me for being that little speck.
And so, there's bits and pieces of that, but I
would say at the end of the day, when you come
out of it's not like you had this epiphany. It's
more like, Dr. Jenn calls it the ketamine's time,
she calls it time-on brain. How can we make
this sit and do the rewiring on your brain
and give you time-on brain with the drug and the
compound and let it do its work? And so it was
a lot of surrendering. It was a lot of saying,
"You do what you want to do. I don't care where
you take me emotionally, mentally, whatever.
It doesn't really matter." It's time-on brain
with a compound. And after a certain number
of sessions, you just feel this natural lift
and lightness. And it felt like, I'm not a
ballerina, big surprise, but it felt like a
little bit of walking through life is a little
bit of a dance now than it is such a struggle.
Tim Ferriss: It makes me super
happy, man, to hear that.
Kevin Rose: It feels amazing.
Tim Ferriss: And I remember getting the texts,
some of the texts from you, and I was excited
to have this conversation. Which we haven't had,
this is the first time we're talking about it.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, it is.
Tim Ferriss: And I'll say a few things. The first
is that, I have seen a number of cases where
ketamine therapy has changed or saved lives. So,
a friend of mine, for instance, who suffered from
depression his entire adult life had a similar
experience to yours. And he went to a clinic,
I believe it was in New York City, very well
run. And he goes back once every six months for
a single tune-up, let's say just say —
Kevin Rose: Call it a booster, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: — session. And I actually know,
I'm also not going to mention their name,
but someone we know as a mutual friend who
you probably don't know also does this once
every three to six months. And separately, I know
someone who's in law enforcement who is heavily
dis-incentivized from talking about mental health
with his superiors because you'll be put on leave
generally, if you even hinted that and you're in
certain professions, airline pilot for instance,
you're going to be put on leave and it's —
Kevin Rose: "On leave" is a nice way
to say you're probably fired.
Tim Ferriss: — it's a nice way.
It's a career risk to bring these things
up, which puts many more people at risk,
right? There should be a bit of processes for
this. But nonetheless, he was suicidal at one
point. We're talking about somebody who
was carrying around a firearm all day. And
ketamine was an intervention that was incredibly
effective for him for pattern interrupting. And I
use that very literally, because the pattern was a
thought loop. This is personal, this is permanent,
this is never going to change. And when
you're able to at least interrupt that for
a short period of time, you provide people with
hope or at least a window within which they can
consider other options. So for acute suicide,
suicidal ideation, also for chronic pain,
very interestingly, ketamine is super interesting.
Kevin Rose: Oh, yes. It's interesting you say that
because Dr. Jenn over at this clinic has told
me she's treated quite a few people for chronic
pain as well, and it works quite well.
Tim Ferriss: So I unexpectedly, because —
Kevin Rose: Have you done it?
Tim Ferriss: So before I talked to anyone about
anything like this, generally I am volunteering
to be the monkey shot into space. So several years
ago I did six sessions over three weeks.
Kevin Rose: Ketamine?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: Oh, shit.
Dude, why did you never tell me this?
Tim Ferriss: I didn't realize I didn't tell
you. So I did six sessions, this would've been —
Kevin Rose: With a mask on and in the music.
Tim Ferriss: In this particular case it was
music, but it was not mask on. The way that
this particular clinic ran things was with video,
which was very strange to me. But nonetheless,
it was sort of nature-scapes. And I was like,
"okay, well this is new to me, I'll try it."
And it ended up being supremely interesting.
I was not going in with an acute condition,
so it was hard for me to evaluate ultimately a
lot of the efficacy. They found it very strange
and I found it hilarious because they would
do an intake each day of active sessions.
Kevin Rose: That's what —
Tim Ferriss: And they would
ask me to do various assessments for anxiety, and
my anxiety levels were going up over time, which
they found very confusing, because, you may have
experienced a little bit of this, ketamine can
compromise your short-term memory, in the short
term, after a session, so you might forget where
your wallet is or forget where your backpack is.
Kevin Rose: I didn't have any of that.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. So that can happen, and
that happened to me. And it happened to be the
case that while I was doing these sessions,
because I shoehorned it into my schedule,
I also had a number of huge podcasts coming
up like LeBron James and so on, and it was
freaking me out that I kept forgetting
shit, and so my anxiety was going up —
Kevin Rose: Oh, that's amazing.
Tim Ferriss: Over the course of
treatment, which was not typical of me.
Kevin Rose: So I did the same thing. They
gave me a whole breakdown. It was one
to five on a bunch of different scales.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: I think it's a pretty
standardized thing that they give you. I
can't remember what the anxiety scales are,
but mine went down to literally a one on all of
them, or a zero on all of them, which is amazing.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. It is amazing. And I want to
mention a few other things. I'm sure Huberman's
episode is excellent. For people who want to have
a comprehensive overview of ketamine, I'm sure
Huberman's is great, so listen to that first.
Kevin Rose: It's fantastic.
Tim Ferriss: I also did an episode
with John Krystal, Dr. John Krystal,
who is the chairman of psychiatry at Yale, who
did a lot of the seminal research with respect
to ketamine as an antidepressant in humans. So
the protocols that get used, which I think are
generally 0.5 milligrams per kilogram of body
weight, et cetera, over X period of time with
Y number of infusions, those are the protocols
that he developed with his other investigators.
And I want to mention a number of things just
to make sure that I'm doing my safety-first
Ferriss duty. So the first is that part of
the reason, and this is pure speculation,
but I think that it was risky for Matthew Perry to
use ketamine, is that he had a history of abuse.
Ketamine can be very addictive for people
who are unwilling or uneager to feel certain
things. It's a dissociative anesthetic. So if you
have, for instance, a history of alcohol abuse,
it is, I would say, increasingly likely
that you might abuse ketamine, which is why,
if someone were to consider ketamine therapy,
I feel very strongly that it should be IV or —
Kevin Rose: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Intramuscular
injection and not at-home treatment —
Kevin Rose: Oh, a hundred percent.
Tim Ferriss: Where you have access
to, say, lozenges or a nasal spray.
Kevin Rose: A hundred percent, because there
are companies that do lozenges at home.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, I completely agree.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah.
Kevin Rose: But I will say one thing,
Tim, real quick and I'll let you continue.
I noticed my desire for alcohol go down.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. I think that that can happen.
And I'm just saying for folks who, for instance,
may be coming out of or are part of AA —
Kevin Rose: Oh, yes.
Tim Ferriss: And they have
issues with depression —
Kevin Rose: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: My personal take,
after everything I've seen, is that prior abuse
of alcohol highly correlated to potential abuse
of ketamine. And I would say, furthermore,
there are some urological risks if you use
ketamine chronically, and alongside that, if
you use ketamine chronically, and this is true
for a lot of drugs, actually, not all of them.
Kevin Rose: That's for snorting though, right?
Tim Ferriss: Do a self-check. I mean, snorting —
Kevin Rose: Because it wouldn't get in your
urological tract, otherwise because
it would metabolize in the liver.
Tim Ferriss: Well, most people who
consume ketamine recreationally —
Kevin Rose: Oh, it would be their mouth, or —
Tim Ferriss: It will be a lot of,
it will be snorting of one way —
Kevin Rose: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Of one sort or another. So they'll
either have it in — it will be in suspension in
a liquid, or it will be a powder they snort
in the same way they would snort cocaine. A
lot of people carry little lockets around their
necks with ketamine. I've seen this a lot and —
Kevin Rose: And by the way, that's
not what I'm talking about here today.
Tim Ferriss: No. No, no, no. I'm not —
Kevin Rose: But those are
two very different things.
Tim Ferriss: No, no. They are, they
are. So just to be very clear, ketamine
therapy with IV or IM has a track record
of being incredibly promising for a —
Kevin Rose: Trained physician —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, for a number of other things.
Kevin Rose: Like proper — yeah.
Tim Ferriss: But where some folks get lost
is they go from, instead of clinical setting,
higher-dose supervised, they bleed
into more casual recreational use.
Kevin Rose: Right.
Tim Ferriss: In which case, it's very
important for me to say that ketamine can be very
helpful for people with, say, treatment-resistant
depression or chronic depression. If you use it
chronically though, it flips the other way and it
actually makes you predisposed to more depression.
So it's just something for people to be aware of.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: And as is true with so many things —
Kevin Rose: Oh, my God.
Tim Ferriss: More is not better.
Kevin Rose: Do you know what — what was the
drug that Michael Jackson died of? Do you
remember the name of that?
Tim Ferriss: I'm not sure.
I think it was a synthetic opioid or —
Kevin Rose: No, no, no. It was basically —
Tim Ferriss: Some type of anesthetic?
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I'm not sure.
Kevin Rose: So it was funny. I went
and — because I'm old now, in my 40s, I went to
have my first colonoscopy because you're supposed
to do that shit, you know?
Tim Ferriss: Party time.
Kevin Rose: Have you done that yet or no?
Tim Ferriss: I have, yes.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, so I went and did mine. And —
Tim Ferriss: And by the way, this is very sad,
but do not skip your fucking colonoscopies.
Kevin Rose: No.
Tim Ferriss: A very good friend of mine
since we last spoke, Roland Griffiths,
who's an amazing scientist from Johns
Hopkins, he died of terminal cancer.
Kevin Rose: Oh, Jesus. Sorry, man.
Tim Ferriss: And I had a long conversation
with him a few days before he died, before I went
to South America. He was completely razor sharp up
until the end. And my recollection is that part
of the reason that was caught too late is that
he was a few years late in having his exam.
Kevin Rose: And so I had mine done and they
caught a couple pre-cancerous, as
they do with most people these days.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Do your fucking screens.
Kevin Rose: And you've got to do your screens. But
anyway, long story short, when I was going in, the
anesthesiologist came in the room and he was kind
of a funny guy. It was cool. I like those guys.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: And I asked him, I said, "Can
I have this slow ramp?" And he is like,
"What's a slow ramp?" And I'm like, "Where you
just kind of give it to me a little bit of time,
just because I feel like going into that zone.”
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: And he's like, "It's funny you say
that." He's like, "I'm giving you the same drug
they gave Michael Jackson when he died." And I
was like, "Oh, that's crazy." I'm like, "Why?" And
he's like, "He was just addicted to it." And so he
gave me the slow ramp, and I remember this feeling
about probably, let's call it 30 seconds into it,
where I felt like I was okay with dying. It was
just this moment of like, "This is beautiful."
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: And I was like, "Oh, my God. This
is what Michael Jackson was feeling right now."
Tim Ferriss: Propofol.
Kevin Rose: Propofol.
Kevin Rose: Propofol. Yeah, exactly.
Tim Ferriss: Propofol.
Kevin Rose: That was it.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Kevin Rose: And so I get it,
but this is to the point of Matthew Perry
dying in the pool. This stuff puts you under.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: It puts you under
so that you can have surgery.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah.
Kevin Rose: And that is what
ketamine does as well, so it's like —
Tim Ferriss: And ketamine, broadly speaking, is
an incredibly well-tolerated safe drug. Part of
the reason that ketamine is, I believe,
listed in the World Health Organization's
Top 100 most essential medicines —
Kevin Rose: 100 most — yeah, exactly.
Tim Ferriss: Is because it is
generally very well-tolerated —
Kevin Rose: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: And it does not suppress respiration.
Kevin Rose: Yes, exactly.
Tim Ferriss: Right?
Kevin Rose: Which is a huge one.
Tim Ferriss: Right. Gigantic. And
it's an incredible compound. And you just need
to know the risk profile. And there are risk
profiles for everything.
Kevin Rose: Of course.
Tim Ferriss: We have tequila and we have water
in front of us. Water has a risk profile, too.
Kevin Rose: It does.
Tim Ferriss: People die
every year of hyponatremia —
Kevin Rose: Did you hear about that —
Tim Ferriss: Because they drink too much
water when they're training for or running
in a marathon, and that causes disruption
of sort of electrochemical signaling. And
then boom, they drop. People die every year.
Kevin Rose: You probably didn't hear about this,
but there was a radio host DJ —
Tim Ferriss: Oh, he's fucking —
Kevin Rose: Do you remember this? Do you know what
I'm talking about?
Tim Ferriss: Where
they have these water-drinking competitions?
Kevin Rose: The water-drinking competitions.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. People died.
Kevin Rose: And somebody died of overdosing
on water.
Tim Ferriss: This has happened many times, right?
Kevin Rose: It's so crazy.
Tim Ferriss: As Paracelsus would say,
"The dose makes the poison,” but sometimes the
frequency and the use pattern makes the poison.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: And I think
ketamine is incredibly interesting and for —
Kevin Rose: Yeah, especially — because when
you get into the actual science behind it, we're
not just using this as an escape. It's actually
rewiring the brain.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: And Huberman will get into
the kind of neurology behind it and what's
happening and why these are more lasting
changes and why some people, not everyone,
but some people can go and do this and they
don't ever have to go back for a booster or
anything else, and it changes them forever.
So I don't know if I should get into this.
Tim Ferriss: We can always cut it.
Kevin Rose: Well, someone very close to me,
she was closest to suicide and she's a dear
friend. She's a sweetheart of a person. And she
was the first time I had ever heard of ketamine
therapy. This was probably four years ago. And
she said, "I was about to take..." The closest
to taking in her life. And she had heard about
ketamine therapy. It was kind of new at the time.
And she paid for the six pack, the six sessions,
the full six. And she hated every single
session. And it was funny, when I talked to
Dr. Jenn at the clinic that I went to, she said,
"It's very common, people that have depression,
they don't enjoy the experience." And I thought
it was fantastic. I loved the whole thing. But
when my friend said that at session six, she
heard a pop in her brain, like a physical pop.
Tim Ferriss: It's like a psychic —
Kevin Rose: Chiropractic.
Tim Ferriss: Adjustment.
Kevin Rose: Literally, the depression
lifted and she has been amazing ever since.
Tim Ferriss: So wild.
Kevin Rose: And this has been like five years ago.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: And it's like, I believe
her. She's doing insanely well now.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: And it's like, "Oh,
my God. Dude." So Tim, I just want to one, thank
you for how much money and effort you've put into
psychedelic research because —
Tim Ferriss: Thanks, man.
Kevin Rose: After experiencing this, I
realized that there is something here.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: And we don't have it figured out.
Kevin Rose: Obviously,
we don't. We're in the baby stages.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: But 10, 20, 30 years with
AI, maybe 10 years, this will get figured
out and it will be largely because people
like you help fund this type of research.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, thanks, man.
Kevin Rose: So I just want
to say thank you for that.
Tim Ferriss: Thank you for saying that, brother.
Kevin Rose: It means a lot.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I really appreciate that.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: And I was so
happy to see those texts.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I was so happy.
Kevin Rose: Well, I've got to tell you,
if you're in the L.A. area, and obviously you'll
talk to her as a doctor, this is her advice, not
ours, and you'll go through the whole screening
process. But goldenafternoon.clinic, I think,
is the website, and she is an amazing human, very
caring, comes in pre and post checks in on you
like a really well run facility. Depression,
anxiety, PTSD, war veterans, all these people
are going in to see her and it's great. It's God's
work, whoever you believe in God or not. I get it.
Tim Ferriss: There are some great clinics
out there. I will say there are also a
lot of fly-by-night clinics.
Kevin Rose: A hundred percent.
Tim Ferriss: So do your homework.
Kevin Rose: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: One of the main advantages,
or it is a main advantage, of ketamine as
compared to other psychedelics, is that in
the United States, it is currently legal.
Kevin Rose: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: And that is a non-trivial
advantage. And I will say that one question you
may want to ask in doing your due diligence,
if you consider this as an option, and I do
feel after canvassing many different compounds,
many different treatments that for acute
suicidal ideation, that ketamine is at the
very top of the list. It is on a very short list
of interventions that having credible promise
for at least creating the space for someone to
consider treatment options. And the question, the
due diligence question that I recommend, and this
is true for any type of drug-assisted therapy,
it's actually true for surgeons too. It's true for
doctors in general. Ask them what types of adverse
events they have observed, what type of abuse
potential they have observed. If their answer is,
"Everything is always fine. We've never had
an adverse event," that is a huge red flag.
Kevin Rose: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Anyone who has enough mileage,
if they are ketamine clinic physician, if they
are an ER physician, they will be able to tell you
what things look like when things go sideways —
Kevin Rose: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: And how they handle those situations.
And if they don't volunteer any of that,
it means either they're inexperienced
or they're delusional, generally.
Kevin Rose: Yeah. A hundred percent.
Tim Ferriss: And I'm giving people a bit
of a break or it means they're lying.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: And in all three cases,
you do not want to have anything to
do with that particular practitioner.
Kevin Rose: By the way, I looked her up,
she's at Princeton.
Tim Ferriss: Princeton?
Kevin Rose: Yep.
Tim Ferriss: Go,
Tigers. Look at that.
Kevin Rose: That's where
my doctor went in Princeton.
Tim Ferriss: And Phil Wolfson,
for instance, has done a lot of writing on
this. Do your homework. You are signing up for,
let's just call it psychoactive brain surgery.
So to the extent that you would do your due
diligence related to a surgeon who is going
to be physically opening your head, carving a
hole in your skull and performing manual brain
surgery, do a commensurate amount of homework
on the person who is going to be providing
you with compounds that have a significant
impact on cognitive functioning. Not necessarily
only in the short term, but in the longer term.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: You want to
hear another crazy drug story?
Kevin Rose: Let's hear it. That's why we're here.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. All right. I'll give you a
refill. Speaking of drugs, Andrew Huberman would —
Kevin Rose: Not be pleased.
Tim Ferriss: He would disapprove.
Kevin Rose: Neither would Attia —
Tim Ferriss: Disapprove —
Kevin Rose: Although Attia likes straight tequila.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, occasionally Attia will have a
drink or two. He just knows what
he's signing up for. And anyway,
we can come back to this. Part of the reason that
I had a wild experience in Portugal recently,
no matter how much wine I have there, I do not
have a headache the next day. And I think it's
additive-related. I can feel tired, it will fuck
up my sleep. At the end of the day, it is alcohol.
But fascinating how different my physiological
response can be. In any case, that's true with
this stuff too for me personally with long.
Kevin Rose: That's great to hear, considering
I'm consuming a good portion of it.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah,
a good portion. All right, so let's —
Kevin Rose: Oh, I've got to talk to you
about my tattoo at some point.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. Should we?
All right. You know what, I'm going to leave that
as a cliffhanger. We're going to come back to —
Kevin Rose: Yeah, we've got to come back to that.
Tim Ferriss: Wild drug story —
Kevin Rose: Because that's why I'm here in town.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I didn't know that.
Kevin Rose: Oh, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
Kevin Rose: You're going to hear about
the crazy machine.
Tim Ferriss: What? Okay,
let's tattoo and crazy machine. What's going on?
Kevin Rose: So —
Tim Ferriss: What's the
bracelet with the skull on it?
Kevin Rose: Oh, that's just a —
Tim Ferriss: Bracelet and skulls.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, bracelet and skulls.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Kevin Rose: So one of the premier generative
artists, and by when I say generative,
what I mean by that, for those that don't
know, is there's a whole genre of art that
is code-based that you write actually computer
science code and you create art. And one of the
premier artists in this space that's been sold at
Christie's and Sotheby's and all over the place is
Tyler Hobbs. He is based here in Austin.
Tim Ferriss: He's such an awesome guy,
too. Another sweetheart guy.
Kevin Rose: By the way, he told me he has
always enjoyed hanging out with you.
Tim Ferriss: Oh.
Kevin Rose: So he's hanging
out with you a couple of times.
Tim Ferriss: He's a nice guy.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: He and his wife
are just lovely beyond words.
Kevin Rose: Such great people, yeah. And so Tyler
lives here and in Austin and his NFTs, you can
say what you want of NFTs, but his NFTs are just
absolutely gorgeous pieces of artwork. And he can
sell for, at times, millions of dollars.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: They're really sought after. So —
Tim Ferriss: Also a legit visual
artist outside of code.
Kevin Rose: Oh, my God.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: I went to his
studio today and he pulled open binders that
he's been doing for decades of his visual art.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, so fun. So fun.
Kevin Rose: And it's just like he's not in
this for the quote, unquote NFTs.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: He is an artist to his core. And so
one of the things that — he always likes to — he
strikes me as the person who is always
saying, "What's next? How can I push things
in a different direction, right?" And there's a
company based out here called Blackdot that has
a machine. It's a robot that uses not tattoo
needles, but you know when people get their
eyebrows cosmetically tattooed on?
Tim Ferriss: I can imagine it.
Kevin Rose: Well, it's a common thing.
Some, I don't want to be gender-based here,
but it's mostly women that get
it tattooed on as their eyebrows.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: But they use a much finer
needle than they would, say, a tattoo gun.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Kevin Rose: And so this robot, this machine, uses
these really fine needles and what they do is they
take, and we can put this in the video as well,
they take and they put this kind of template on
your arm that is more or less just almost like a
QR of massive QR code kind of grid on your arm.
Tim Ferriss: Wow, okay.
Kevin Rose: So that's my forearm.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I was wondering about that. You
sent me a text and I was like, "What the hell? Is
that your tattoo?" Okay.
Kevin Rose: No.
Tim Ferriss: No, it's just like a giant QR code.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, like a giant QR code across
my forearm. And that allows the optical
lenses and the lasers and everything to
align the tattoo. It is doing 17,000 small
micro pushes into my skin with this needle.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Kevin Rose: And it does it. They can gauge
with these depth sensors, the correct depth of
the dermis to go in so that the ink doesn't spread
out and fade over time so they can do insanely
high-fidelity tattoos. Like stuff you've never —
it's like picture perfect. Even when you see those
pictures of like, "Oh, that person got that baby
tattooed on their chest. How cute." Imagine 10 x
the fidelity of that where you'd be like somebody
took a picture and pasted it on their chest.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: They have a machine that can do that.
Tim Ferriss: So you're never getting
those off until you change your mind.
Kevin Rose: What this is Tyler started with,
he drew me a sparrow, and the reason I like a
sparrow is because to me a sparrow is the most
common low ego bird to me that's out there. I'm
just getting a little sensitive, but it reminds
me that we're all just sparrows.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: We don't need to take each
other — no one's better than anyone else.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: We're all a common
bird. We're all humans, right? And then what he
did is he applied an algorithm to it that degrades
the bird into a pixelated form over three images.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, that's cool. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Kevin Rose: And so the last one is his last
algorithm of the more pixelated version. And
so you can imagine I'm getting this
tattooed on my arm tomorrow. And —
Tim Ferriss: So wait, you're getting
it tattooed tomorrow, what is that?
Kevin Rose: This is just stencil.
Tim Ferriss: Ah. Okay.
Kevin Rose: So I wanted to show you this
today of what the stencil will look like.
Tim Ferriss: Cool.
Kevin Rose: So you can
imagine a world where literally in the future —
Tim Ferriss: How long does that stencil last?
Kevin Rose: You could wipe it off with some
alcohol and stuff, but it's just there for
the show of the show. But you can imagine a
world where he can give you an algorithm like
he does with his artwork, and you can walk in,
put your arm underneath this machine and get a
unique generative piece by an artist that is one
of one unique to you as defined by an insanely
famous artist. Imagine if, let's backtrack here,
but Picasso had the tools in his day to say,
"I'm going to create an algorithm that is a bunch
of crazy swirls and chaos that is my brain."
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, or a Banksy or whoever.
Kevin Rose: Based on whoever. And you stick
your arm in and you get a one-on-one Picasso.
They're only doing three of them. This is a brand
new machine, brand new technology.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
Kevin Rose: And so that's why I'm out here to do a
one-on-one, Tyler Hobbs on my arm with a sparrow.
Tim Ferriss: That's cool.
Kevin Rose: So that's tomorrow.
Tim Ferriss: Blackdot?
Kevin Rose: Blackdot,
yeah. It's a new kind of startup out here.
Tim Ferriss: And here in Austin. Man,
there's a lot happening in here.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: There's a lot happening. That's cool.
Kevin Rose: It's so cool. Yeah, I want to show
you the one they did of the Mona Lisa.
It's amazing stuff. You don't have — do
you have any tattoos at all? You don't, do you?
Tim Ferriss: No. I've been thinking about getting
my first, which is why I asked about the stencil.
Kevin Rose: So look at that.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, yeah.
Kevin Rose: It's like
just the eyes of the Mona Lisa right there. But
look how high fidelity that is in the forearm.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that's wild.
Kevin Rose: It's insane.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that's fast pretty wild.
Kevin Rose: So you've been
thinking about getting one?
Tim Ferriss: I've been thinking about
getting one for years, which would be —
Kevin Rose: What would you do? Molly.
Tim Ferriss: Molly's paw prints on my forearm.
Kevin Rose: You would not.
Tim Ferriss: What was that?
Kevin Rose: You would not. Are you serious?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: That'd be kind of awesome.
Kevin Rose: How old is Molly now?
Tim Ferriss: Molly is eight.
Kevin Rose: Oh, is it —
Tim Ferriss: Between eight and nine.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, Toaster is
slowing down, man.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: It's tough.
Tim Ferriss: It's so sad.
Kevin Rose: There's nothing more heartbreaking
than starting to see your dog start to go.
Tim Ferriss: On the decline.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: He is falling now. His
legs are falling out from underneath him.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, no.
Kevin Rose: I know. It's the worst. We don't have
to take the podcast there, but yeah, it's bad.
Tim Ferriss: But hey, Toaster has
been with the podcast since day one.
Kevin Rose: Remember when he’d chew on
the cables? He's like he was going to —
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I do. I was just going
to bring it up, man. Back in the day,
this was still Digg era, I guess, and we were at
your apartment in San Francisco and he was just a
little pup chewing on the cables.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I remember that.
Kevin Rose: He was Toast.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: He's still kicking it though.
Mentally, he's sharp as shit, which is great.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: Which is nice.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it's nice to see him.
We were playing with him. Friendly Toast.
Kevin Rose: Yeah. What a great dog.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. So for me, it's hard for me to
imagine a world or any circumstances in which I
would regret having the paw prints on my arm.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: And there are many others —
Kevin Rose: How much has that dog meant
for you personally? Because I've seen
you through multiple relationships.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: Dogs are like this thing
that is just like this steadfast love.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: Has it been a good — I mean,
obviously, it must been an insane emotional lift
for you to have an animal like that in your life.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. It has changed me fundamentally
on so many different ways, I think. And
it's not just the receipt of that love,
which is — it's like a task in and of itself,
right? I mean, like to — and I actually saw this
at one point. Somebody had sketched it onto this
piece of wood and I came across it and it was like
your task in life is to learn how to love and be
loved. That's it. And being loved is actually not
straightforward for everyone, right?
Kevin Rose: Mm-hmm.
Tim Ferriss: Learning to receive that in
a way. So that has been a gift, but it's
also been a practice of giving and thinking
about someone else's welfare. And having, say,
a dog as a mirror also for yourself, where let's
just say early on when I was training Molly and I
took the training super seriously.
Kevin Rose: Oh, my God. I was
there for that.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: You were so serious.
Tim Ferriss: And I ended up being pretty good
at it. And Molly is very well-trained. But if she
fucked up or made a mistake, I would get upset.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: And —
Kevin Rose: Or you would hit her.
Tim Ferriss: No.
Kevin Rose: I'm just kidding. I'm just kidding.
Tim Ferriss: Jesus Christ.
Kevin Rose: I'm exaggerating.
Tim Ferriss: I did not hit my dog.
Kevin Rose: Sorry.
Tim Ferriss: And beat her
with a rod. So no, I wouldn't hit
Molly. But I would get very frustrated.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: And then that would scare
her. And not because I was lashing out, but I
would just get so frustrated because I'd be like,
"God, this is the 37th time we've done this." It
was a mirror because Molly is not doing anything
deliberately to piss me off.
Kevin Rose: Right.
Tim Ferriss: That's ridiculous.
Tim Ferriss: And so it was an incredible
reflection in the pond for me to see what
was going on and to see what's going
on with me, right? I'm short-tempered.
Kevin Rose: Mm-hmm.
Tim Ferriss: If you're with other people,
you can weave a story to justify it.
Kevin Rose: Right.
Tim Ferriss: Right. Well, they should
know like, "God, I didn't get sleep,
and they know that, and dah, dah, dah, dah."
Kevin Rose: Yeah. They've done this.
Tim Ferriss: "Why does it always have
to be in the morning that they blah,
blah, blah?" You can really spin a yarn to
rationalize why you're upset with someone else,
but a really loving, well-behaved dog, are
you kidding? That's a you problem, pal.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: That is not a dog problem.
Tim Ferriss: And so on
all of those levels, she has just been such
a wonderful companion and teacher. And I was
away from her for a few weeks recently for the
first time because I was in South America and
absolutely not the right place for a dog where
I was in the middle of the jungle. And I really,
really missed her. So I mean, God, I'm really
like, "Take us there." But when I think about,
which I do pretty often, when she has her
decline and then passes, it's heartbreaking
for me to imagine. And I'm going to get a second
dog almost certainly in the next year. That would
be on my New Year's resolutions too. And
I've thought about this for a few years,
but I've pushed it off because there's part of me
that doesn't want to accept that Molly is mortal.
So I push it off and push it off but it's time —
Kevin Rose: It's good to do it on the sooner side
because when they're older, I could never
introduce another dog to Toaster right
now because he’s too old to handle that
puppy energy versus if you did it now,
then they can chill with each other.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. And Molly is really good
with puppies and she loves puppies.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So I'm going to do that very
soon in the next year. And I at one point
was volunteering, it's a long story, but I was
volunteering around wolves and I was preparing the
food and so on for these wolves, which were —
Kevin Rose: Yeah, those are the ones
that licked you in the teeth and stuff.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Which were being sort
of rehabilitated and raised in captivity because
they'd either been bred and raised in captivity,
in which case they can't be released, or there are
any number of conditions that led to them being
non-viable as wild releases. And I saw one of the
volunteers had — I think it was on his rib cage,
he had a print from this wolf that he
had known for years until that wolf
passed away. And I thought to myself, "You
know what? I've never felt pulled to have a
tattoo." And the fact that I have no tattoos
is kind of novel now, which is funny, right?
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss:
Tattoos are pretty common.
Kevin Rose: Oh, you've got
to go to Jess, my lady. She's amazing.
Tim Ferriss: So I might, I might. And I thought,
"I really have a hard time imagining regretting
doing that, and I can also see it being a really
valuable reminder of a lot."
Kevin Rose: Oh, my God. Tim,
I've got something for you.
Tim Ferriss: Yup.
Kevin Rose: Listen to this.
Tim Ferriss: Tell me.
Kevin Rose: You know how I
said someone was going to
play at my birthday?
Tim Ferriss: Yes.
Kevin Rose: Jess is going to
be out there at the same time.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Kevin Rose: Why don't
you sign up to get the tattoo?
Tim Ferriss: At the party?
Kevin Rose: I mean, not at the party, but the
day before, the day after or something like that.
Tim Ferriss: Oh. All right, all right.
Kevin Rose: And she has booked out by a year.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Kevin Rose: She did Bruce Willis'
tattoos. No, she's legit as they come.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, she's legit.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. All right.
Kevin Rose: Jessmachete on Instagram. Insane.
Tim Ferriss: All right. Now she's
booked out for five years.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, exactly.
Tim Ferriss: I just —
Kevin Rose: We'll book her up.
Tim Ferriss: I'll pull up the strings.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: This has been on my list for a
while. It's been on my list for a couple of years,
and I think partially because I'm nervous.
Kevin Rose: You would love her.
So can I ask you a question?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: I want to ask you a question that is
a little bit more intimate just because we've had
some tequila and we're talking about dogs and
just kind of the companionship and whatnot.
Speaking of kind of New Year's resolutions and
looking back on life, in the last 10 years,
when it comes to both personal, either
intimate relationships or private,
if there's any one thing, what would you change
about your interactions with either someone that
you've been with on an intimate level or someone
that maybe it's on a more kind of friendship
level. Is there anything that you can look back
on and say, "I would've done more of this?"
Tim Ferriss: That is an exceptional question.
And you know when I was driving over here,
I was thinking about another question. We have the
ultimate cliffhanger and the crazy drug story, so
maybe we'll get to that, maybe we won't. We will
do that the next episode. But I was thinking also,
I was like, "What would Kevin tell his..." I'm
going to ask your question, but I was thinking,
"What would Kevin tell his 30-year-old self, my
current Kevin, do this, maybe not do so much of
that, blah, blah, blah." I thought that could be
a fun exploration. With the interpersonal stuff, I
think that I would say just because someone needs
other things, needs things that are different from
your needs does not make them high maintenance.
And by the way, Tim, if they looked at you through
the same lens you were looking at them through,
they would decide that you are high maintenance.
So gather some tools, right? I would say read
The Five Love Languages, as cheesy and schlocky
as it might seem. That shit is so helpful as
a framework for discussion, for identifying
and easily labeling the different categories of
needs that people might have and putting them in
some type of order. Oh, interesting. You're
a quality time person. Good to know. Number
two would be this. Oh, you're a physical touch
and then acts of service person as I am, right?
These are shared vocabulary that you can use to
really avoid and repair a lot of things, right?
So I would say a handful of things, right? So Gay
and Katie Hendricks, also Conscious Loving. There
are a few books, a few resources that would
say, "Look, if you really care about someone,
commit together to develop a shorthand,
which allows you to not necessarily prevent,
I don't think prevention is the key. I think
repair is the key, right?" If you're in a
startup and you're like, "Well, let's just
prevent all the bad things from happening."
Kevin Rose: Right.
Tim Ferriss: That's never going to work.
Tim Ferriss: Shit is going to happen
and people are going to have bad days, and you're
going to say things you regret and there are going
to be disagreements. And by the way, if there
are no disagreements, something's wrong.
Kevin Rose: Right.
Tim Ferriss: Right?
Kevin Rose: A hundred percent.
Tim Ferriss: And therefore,
having a shorthand and a set of agreements,
these are the rules that we agree to play by
and we're not going to be perfect. I would
say that would be very high on the list.
And I would say for really close relationships,
potentially, maybe we'll edit this out, but who
knows? MDMA-assisted psychotherapy, let's just
say anywhere from once a quarter to once a year,
no more than once a quarter for a whole host of
reasons. But I think that while MDMA-assisted
psychotherapy for PTSD is incredibly impressive,
and I've been very involved with that from,
I don't want to say day one because that's not
true, but certainly for the last 10 years or so,
I've been very involved up through phase three and
now onward. The results with treatment-resistant
PTSD or a complex PTSD, where you see people
who've had this diagnosis for 17 years, suddenly
after two or three sessions end up asymptomatic,
right? They would not meet the criteria for
PTSD with durability out to six, nine, 12 months.
I mean, it's something that almost defies belief,
right? It is causing a complete reexamination
of psychiatry as we know it. I still think that
is second place to couples work when it comes to
MDMA. I think that that is an incredibly fruitful
arena for seeing the full potential of MDMA
psychotherapy. That would be another one. Because
sometimes, oftentimes couples end up, and I know
multiple people now who have had this experience
with professional guidance, which by the way,
folks, currently is illegal. So be forewarned,
there are legal consequences or at least risks
entailed with this. Not to mention the fact
that at least I would say 60 to 70 percent of
MDMA that you might purchase is adulterated or
mixed with something else at this point, so
you need to be very careful. Dancesafe.org
is a resource I would recommend for testing kits
and so on if you're going to go that route. I'm
not recommending you do anything illegal,
however, people are going to do it anyway.
Kevin Rose: You have international listeners.
Tim Ferriss: People are going to do it anyway.
I just recognize it's like you can't just
say to every teenager, "Don't have sex."
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Kids are going to
have sex. So let's be realistic about it.
Kevin Rose: I did that shit one time.
It was fun as shit.
Tim Ferriss: Had sex?
Kevin Rose: No. When I was 23, I did,
well, they were called ecstasy back then,
but holy shit, that is a good compound.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, and that can also go
sideways, just for the record.
Kevin Rose: Oh, no doubt.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. So, there are films out there
now, How to Change Your Mind, the miniseries on
Netflix. Watch the MDMA episode. It is excellent.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: And it's pretty heavy because it gets
into some PTSD, but you'll be able to see live
session footage if you want another alternative.
Kevin Rose: Man, Pollan's a hero.
Tim Ferriss: He's great. And there is
also a doc called Trip of Compassion,
which is worth seeing, which has a lot of
session footage as well. But those are a few
of the things that would come to mind.
Let's say on a friendship level,
I might suggest to my earlier self, let's just
say 30-year-old self, right? Something that I
have really embraced and put into action in the
last handful of years, which is going to sound a
little anti-social, but I don't view it that way.
Humans have a finite capacity for building and
sustaining really deep relationships. You just
can't do that with everyone. And when I've looked
back, say — and I do this every year at a past
year review, and I look back in my calendar every
week of my last year, and on a piece of paper with
positive and negative, two columns, I write down
the peak negative and positive experiences.
If I look at the commonalities for the peak
positive experiences, it's usually the same 10
people, or fewer, right? It's the same cast of
characters. These are my close friends who
are nourishing, supportive, good influence.
And before — what I would say to my younger self
is, "Before you seek to develop a bunch of new
relationships, ask yourself, are you spending
enough time, as much time as you would like,
with the people on that shortlist who you
know are guaranteed to be nourishing for you?"
And if the answer is no, maybe you should double
down on those relationships. Maybe you should
reach out to those people to get something on the
calendar before shit crowds it out, before you
look for shiny objects in new relationships. Which
doesn't mean I don't develop new relationships,
I occasionally do, but I'm at a point where I
think recognizing the ephemeral nature of life,
the finite limits, the constraints that
we have, is actually very enabling.
It helps you to make cleaner, faster decisions.
So for me, I would just say, before seeking to
develop new deep relationships, ask yourself
the question: "For my closest five friends,
let's just say, in the last year, did I spend as
much time as I would like with those people?" If
the answer is no, reach out to those five first.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: What about you?
Kevin Rose: Oh, man. I would say,
honestly, I think that we're at the age now
where every day just brings a new unknown
in terms of how long are we going to last. I've
had multiple friends with cancer now. I had one
friend that I almost lost this year that was in
the emergency room for weeks that we thought had
stage four cancer and it ended up being a horrible
bacterial infection from some foreign country.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I remember this.
Kevin Rose: I just realized there's
so many times when we hang out and we just give
a hug and say, "Oh, good to see you, blah, blah,
blah." But we don't say, "I love you." We don't
say, "You are so essential to me in so many ways."
And maybe this is the ketamine talking, but like
— no, but when I went through this whole thing
with the ketamine therapy, I realized when I came
out of it, I just realized that at the end of the
day, love is the, this is going to sound cheesy,
but it is the most important thing that we tell
each other and that we feel for each other.
And when you can really feel that and you say,
"This person is so important to me," and
you let them know that and you feel it back,
I don't know what's better than that.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Yeah, what's more human
than that too, right?
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: In a way. I mean, love, you can
observe affection and love in many other species,
but the ability to verbalize it and express it.
Kevin Rose: Yeah. Do you feel that psychedelics
brings that out of you? Because when
I did the therapy, I had more love in
me than I've had in so long. Do you feel
that's a commonality amongst psychedelics
to have a sense of just gratitude for existence?
Tim Ferriss: For sure. I think it's very common.
It's not always across the board. I mean, I would
say that this might be a controversial statement,
but the psychedelics, to me, are similar to —
there's a lot more to it, which we'll probably
dive into, but kind of like alcohol, or power,
or money in the sense that they magnify what's
already there and a term you sometimes hear
is a non-specific amplifier. So I don't think
that at all. There's no compelling evidence to me
that psychedelics, if put in the drinking water,
produce world peace, there's no evidence for that.
Right? I mean, you have plenty of civilizations —
Kevin Rose: Maybe lithium though. No,
no, no, remember there was a study.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I remember. I remember.
Yeah, a little bit of lithium goes a long way.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, people can look
this up. We'll try to find, there's some —
Kevin Rose: There's a study that people in
populations where there is more lithium naturally
found in the drinking water have lower rates of
suicide than anywhere else in the world.
Tim Ferriss: All sorts of stuff. Yeah, so
we'll see what we can find. Put in the show notes.
I do think low-dose lithium is pretty interesting.
Very low dose. But psychedelics are a non-specific
amplifier. There are many cases of civilizations
where they had human sacrifice, played soccer
with human heads, and they consumed psychedelics.
Kevin Rose: I still sacrifice people.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah.
Kevin Rose: You know. As we all do.
Tim Ferriss: Every once in a while in
the solstice, I mean, I think it's all fair
game. The feeling of gratitude and love,
I think, for a lot of people who wish
to enable that, to experience it more,
who have the conscious, or subconscious, desire
to rekindle those things, that the experience
you're describing is very common.
Kevin Rose: Yeah. For sure.
Tim Ferriss: I think part of that is the
dissolution, this isn't true of all experiences,
but the dissolution of self and, consequently, the
felt sense of unity with many or all things. Which
leads you to feel, for most people, less alone.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Which leads you to feel quite
grateful because, to state the obvious, I suppose,
despite the fact that we're more connected than
ever with loose ties, I think a lot of people
suffer from anxiety and depression —
Kevin Rose: Oh, for sure.
Tim Ferriss: — that is highly correlated to
feeling of isolation. So, when you can remedy
that by feeling the exact polar opposite
in some of these states, not necessary,
but helpful, that the end result of
that is a feeling of gratitude for sure.
Kevin Rose: Awesome.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: What was the — before we wrap things
up, because I know we're coming to the end and
you still have some tequila to finish. What was
the cliffhanger you said you wanted to tell us?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, so I'll try to keep it short.
I'll let you — I'll tell you what, I'll keep it
short and then you can excavate —
Kevin Rose: Okay.
Tim Ferriss: — as you like.
Kevin Rose: I love to excavate.
Tim Ferriss: All right. So as you know, for
the last year, I've basically been crippled
by lower back issues.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I mean, I've had trouble — there
are days when I've had trouble getting up
and walking. I mean, it's been that bad.
Kevin Rose: Yeah. I mean, to be honest,
Tim, you first told me about this eight years
ago or something. Remember when you got those
injections or something?
Tim Ferriss: Sure.
Kevin Rose: You were like, "I
think I have degenerative disc…"
Tim Ferriss: "...disc disease."
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. So I've had lower back issues
for a long time. This is also a congenital issue.
So I have what's called a transitional segment.
In other words, there's a segment in my lumbar,
there are vertebrae in my lumbar area that
really mimic a sacral vertebral segment and
that's problematic for a host of reasons.
Creates an abnormal angle. And if you can
imagine just bending the paper clip over and
over again in ways that it shouldn't be bent.
That's sort of the feeling in the low back.
My brother has this. There are other people
in my family who have this issue. So standing
extended, slow walking, like a museum walk,
cocktail party type of experience, can be very
painful, like the low back locks up. But in the
last year, specifically, had all sorts of issues
and all sorts of MRIs and specialists, and PT, and
adjustments, and traction and this, that, and the
other thing. And it was a disaster and it caused
a — well, let me give myself a little more agency.
I created a lot of anxiety around this 'cause I
was like, "Fuck, is this the new normal?"
Kevin Rose: Right.
Tim Ferriss: Is this really the new normal where —
Kevin Rose: Well, because you project forward,
what does five years from now look like?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I'm like,
I'm not that old.
Kevin Rose: Right.
Tim Ferriss: And I'm pretty active.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, and your skincare is amazing.
Tim Ferriss: My skincare is amazing.
Kevin Rose: I saw your Instagram —
Tim Ferriss: Oh, boy.
Kevin Rose: — video.
Tim Ferriss: You know what's funny, sidebar,
is how much time you can spend on a blog post.
Takes six months to put together and it's like,
you get crickets and a fart in the wind and then
nobody ever reads it again. And then someone
on your team is like, "You know what, people
ask about your skincare. Let's grab a couple
clips and throw it up," and it goes bananas.
Kevin Rose: I'm on Instagram and the first thing
that pops up to me is like, "Hi, I'm Tim Ferriss.
People ask me about my skincare regimen."
Tim Ferriss: Oh, God.
Kevin Rose: "Let me tell you, I use Bronner's
Natural Soap," or whatever. It's like, "What
the fuck has Tim become into?"
Tim Ferriss: Yeah,
so here we are, folks. Here we are, folks.
Kevin Rose: Your skin looks amazing though.
Tim Ferriss: Thank you. Thank you.
Kevin Rose: Breathtaking.
Tim Ferriss: It's —
Kevin Rose: All natural.
Tim Ferriss: — it's working from the inside out.
So, coming back to the main throughline here,
terrifying experience, the back. And I had more
or less given up. I was in the stage of grief
where I was trying to get past denial and accept
that this might be the new normal because no one
could figure it out. And a lot of the advice I
received, many of the diagnoses were conflicting,
and then I decided, in part because of this,
to do a few things. And part of that was going
to South America, which I'm not recommending,
there are a lot of risks down in South America.
It's generally like safety fifth, it's not
safety first, so people getting into a lot of
trouble. But I went down and did this training,
which involved consuming a bunch of plants,
also involved fasting for a week, also involved —
Kevin Rose: Wait, wait, wait, wait, water fast?
Tim Ferriss: Water fast.
Kevin Rose: Jesus. Seven days?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Also involved during that week,
really not sitting, and standing very little. So
it was either hammock or cot, basically. And
I'm mentioning these things because they're
confounders. Translating that into basic English,
that means that I can't really point back to one
thing and say, "This is what caused what I'm going
to describe." But during the first experience,
which happened to be with ayahuasca, which is a
huge gun, it's, I think, treated very casually
by people who do not realize what they're signing
up for. I do not recommend it to most people. As
my ex, who's going to become relevant in the
second, would tell you, I talk many, many,
many more people. Nine out of 10 —
Kevin Rose: Which ex?
Tim Ferriss: — out of — I'm not going to
mention her name, but out my most recent ex,
out of using ayahuasca than I talk into
using ayahuasca. Nine times out of 10,
I say, "You should not proceed. Do not pass go."
For a lot of reasons. But in this particular case,
had a very, very, very difficult experience.
And I can kind of rank order my hardest
experiences over the last decade plus, and this
would be the third most difficult, maybe the
second for different characteristics, which is
saying a lot. And there was a point at which, in
that experience, all I could imagine was having my
head in the lap of my ex. That's all I wanted. It
was the only thing I could even visualize because
I was in the impact zone. I was just getting hit
by hundred foot waves from every angle. And there
was no respite. It was 10 out of 10. There was no
wave. Meaning, it didn't ebb and flow. It was just
10 out of 10 volume from peak until end of the
night, effectively. It was unusual and incredibly
difficult. And that was true for everyone in the
session. Yeah, well, we'll leave it at that.
Kevin Rose: Your shaman mixed the wrong —
Tim Ferriss: This guy is famous for
having a brew that just cripples people.
Kevin Rose: The crippler.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I mean,
there are a lot of other full-time clinicians from
indigenous traditions who will not drink his brew,
I'll put it that way.
Kevin Rose: Oh, Jesus.
Tim Ferriss: And coming back to the point
of the story, I'm imagining the only thing
I can envision is this woman holding my head
and consoling me. That's the only thing I can
imagine. And then I realized that for a year,
because we separated a bit over a year ago,
and this was totally subconscious, it wasn't a
decision on my part, but I realized I had not
allowed myself to feel the complete obliterating
heartbreak that was in fact the core response to
that separation. I'd not allowed myself to feel —
Kevin Rose: From her or from previous?
Tim Ferriss: From that separation. In other words,
my psyche had seemingly protected me because of my
history of depression. Which I've come to manage
better than ever before. Each year I'm better able
to manage it. And it's less and less frequent.
It's less and less intense. But nonetheless,
let's face the facts, in college I almost
killed myself. So there was a fear, at least
subconsciously, that because of this separation,
because of starting over at square one, that I
could spiral into a deep depression and that
could be dangerous. So my psyche protected me
from that by not letting me feel the sadness, the
pain, to the extent that ended up being important,
which I realized in this moment. So I
allowed myself to soak in it, in that moment.
Trip reports are so fucking boring most of the
time. And I apologize to people who might be
listening and thinking, "God, here we go again,"
because I get it, trust me. But in this particular
case, I experienced something I've never
experienced. As soon as I soaked in that,
and I really soaked in it, it was awful. It
was so dark and so heavy. And then I felt my
back release. And literally I've been 90 plus
percent pain-free since that fucking moment.
And it blows my mind because at that
point, I couldn't explain it with the fast,
because the fast and ketones are highly
anti-inflammatory. And I think that they
actually played a role —
Kevin Rose: Yeah but —
Tim Ferriss: Hold on. In the durability of things.
But the fact that there was an immediate release —
Kevin Rose: Yeah, I was going to say the snap —
Tim Ferriss: — is interesting —
Kevin Rose: — doesn't make sense —
Tim Ferriss: — is interesting. I
can't explain that through fasting. I can't
explain that through the just being recumbent,
laying down for seven days because that was
yet to come. And I would say that I made a
tactical error in the last few weeks, which
is I was like, "Fuck, man, I'm all good."
And so I've neglected some of the basic
self-care and strengthening and PT,
which I think is important because my low
back and QL and so on, which are some of the
surrounding muscles have atrophied over the
last year of avoiding working with the back.
Kevin Rose: Right.
Tim Ferriss: But there was that
experience. And for people who may be interested
in delving into this a little bit more,
there is a book, I don't agree with everything in
the book, but it is interesting in the sense that
it was written by a Western-trained MD who ended
up then opening a healing clinic in South America,
focused on ayahuasca and diets, which you
will read about if you get into the book,
called The Fellowship of the River. So I found
that book quite interesting on a number of
levels. But the reason I bring this all up,
number one, people had recommended this book,
I think it was called [Healing Back Pain].
I may be getting the title slightly wrong,
could be Fixing Low Back Pain, but it's by Dr.
Sarno, John Sarno. And this book was recommended
to me. I've read it before. And the general gist
is, it's all in your head. Now, I took great
offense at parts of this book, and a lot of it
is scientifically indefensible. So unfortunately,
I threw the baby out with the bathwater a bit
because he says a bunch of things that are
ridiculous. And he cites these success statistics
for his method while simultaneously saying, "If I
interview someone and they say they're not open
to A, B, or C, I omit them from my treatment."
Kevin Rose: Right.
Tim Ferriss: And I'm like, okay,
well wait a fucking second. Your selection —
Kevin Rose: Hundred percent —
Tim Ferriss: — is out of control. But I wanted to
bring this up because that book has helped a lot
of people, despite its flaws. And not everyone
will, at any point, want to consume ayahuasca,
which I would advise against for 90-plus percent
of the population, because it can be very
destabilizing for a lot of people and very risky.
I would say there are a lot of things you should
do beforehand. Try the talk therapy,
try holotropic breathwork, consider,
after speaking with doctors, ketamine.
After that, you can consider other tools,
but ayahuasca should be like —
Kevin Rose: Let's do a —
Tim Ferriss: — fifth on your —
Kevin Rose: Let's do a random show on ayahuasca.
Tim Ferriss: We could.
Kevin Rose: Is that possible?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, possibly. Yeah. ayahuasca
would be like fifth or sixth on the list of
progressions. It would not be first. But I
would say the Sarno books are interesting.
I know they've helped people like Brian
Koppelman, who's been on the podcast,
amazing writer who was the co-creator of
Billions, among others, Rounders, etc.
And it's something that I've always, in
theory, agreed with. Yes, we store stress
that can have a physiological effect. There are
autoimmune disorders that I think are intimately
linked with different types of psychological
disturbances. So you can address the problem
kind of from the physiological side first.
Of course, the brain isn't entirely separate.
There's no kind of Cartesian separation of mind
and body. So yes, the brain is physiological,
but you can attack it through content, in a way,
or you can attack it through pharmaceuticals and
physiology first. I think you can go both
ways, but the Sarno book, I think, is worth
a lot of people reading. The second thing I'll
mention, which is very, very simple and tactical.
If you have lower back pain, I'm shocked it took
me this long to figure it out and say, sitting on
hard chairs bothers you, or lumbar support helps
you — for a year, I've been going to restaurants
and asking if they have a cushion. Do you have a
cushion or pillow or something I can use to fix
fucked-up seating situations? This is the solution
right here. This is it. This is a Pilates ball,
this is a pro-body Pilates. It doesn't really
matter. But honestly, this thing folds up, sticks
in your pocket, and I've been traveling with it.
I've had it behind my back the whole time. And —
Kevin Rose: Great for first dates.
Tim Ferriss: Great for first dates. Ladies
love Pilates balls. But I will say, for instance,
the last time I did a podcast in this seat,
I did not use this and my back was fucking killing
me afterwards. But the killing me afterwards is
not just an issue for today. That's an issue that
causes inflammation, that fucks up my sleep for
three or four days. Use this ball, no problem. I
can put it behind my back or I can put it under
my ass and it folds up and fits in your pocket.
So, anyways, folks, there you have it from the
sublime to the ridiculous Pilates ball.
Kevin Rose: Amazing. All right,
how are we doing? Any other topics?
Tim Ferriss: I feel pretty good. Next time
we'll get to what you would tell your 30-year-old
self. Anything you'd like to add in that category?
Kevin Rose: No, I think if we're
— are we wrapping up now? Because
I'd like to say some wrapping up comments.
Tim Ferriss: Wrapping up comments, please.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, so my wrapping up comments
would be this, I recently went out to dinner
with five close friends of mine, who of which
you know most of them. Just like the crew.
Tim Ferriss: The Wu-Tang Clan.
Kevin Rose: Yeah. Just good friends, and one of
the things I did is I went around the circle and
I said a few words of gratitude. And I think to
my earlier point, one of the things that's really
important to me, after coming out of this therapy,
is just this vulnerability that allows us to speak
from the heart because we don't know what tomorrow
brings. And I just want to say that, Tim, you have
been a friend of mine for so long now, and I have
appreciated the fact that my career has been a
series of ups and downs and all over the place.
And you have been a steadfast friend, someone that
sends me some of the funniest videos I've ever
seen in my life, always keeps it lighthearted and
fun, but I know that you care deeply about me. And
I just want to let you know that I love you and
I care deeply about you, and I'll always be here
to have your back. And I'm wishing you a fantastic
new year. I hope that you hit all these milestones
and more that you want to hit. Because I know that
you are someone that I've always looked up to,
and someone that is just so inspirational to us
all that listen to your show and your podcast
because you inspire us to do more, and to be
better humans. And I just want to let you know
that that means a lot to me, and I love you.
Tim Ferriss: Thanks, Kevin. That's
amazing. That makes my night and —
Kevin Rose: Happy to say it. It's the truth.
Tim Ferriss: I love you too, man. Our
friendship has been such a constant for me,
such a lifeline, in a way, with all the ups
and downs and holy shit, I mean, both of us
have had some pretty wily ups and downs.
Kevin Rose: I mean, you've had a lot of
hot chicks you've dated. I will say —
Tim Ferriss: I didn't see that coming.
Kevin Rose: When you talked about
the ups and downs, I was like,
you've got a lot of ups, my friend.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. I mean, look,
that's one category — that's the one category —
Kevin Rose: I had to lighten up the mood a
little bit.
Tim Ferriss:
And I'm grateful for that. And life
is like a box of chocolates, right?
You just never know what's around the corner.
Kevin Rose: It's true, it's true and that's
why it's important to say these things.
Tim Ferriss: It is. It is. And I have,
I have — I'll tell you something you don't know,
I have your Christmas/New Year's card from two
years ago. So, obviously at a date, it's like you
and Darya and the kids, and it's up in my kitchen.
Kevin Rose: Amazing.
Tim Ferriss: And I kept it there because I love
seeing you guys every day, and I think about you
guys all the time and just have such love for your
family. And I'm so grateful for our friendship. So
I love you too, man, as you said, it's important
to say. Things are so uncertain.
Kevin Rose: Uncertain.
Tim Ferriss: I've never experienced —
I've had friends pass from cancer before —
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: — but I've never been with
them through — I've never been there every step of
the way, from diagnosis to last conversation a few
days before they passed, that was new for me. And
it really deeply affected me on a bunch of levels.
And I want to be deeply affected by that. I don't
want to push that aside. In part, because Roland
was so joyful and curious and optimistic until the
end. In a very genuine way. It wasn't an act. It
wasn't theater. That raised a bunch of aspirations
in me because he was, first and foremost, a very
dedicated, seasoned meditator. Psychedelics were
a piece of the puzzle. But, first and foremost,
he was a dedicated meditator for decades.
Kevin Rose: That's amazing.
Tim Ferriss: And attributed a lot of his
equanimity and preparation for death,
which I got to see firsthand. A lot of people talk
about it, but let's be honest, or I'll be honest,
I've read all the Stoics or a lot of the Stoics,
and I've read all sorts of Buddhism and rehearsed
death and memento mori and this, that and
the other thing. But when I'm actually on,
as Roland said, the final glide path, I don't know
how I'm going to respond. I don't know. I have no
idea. So to see someone who really walked the walk
in such a life-affirming way that lit everyone up
around him was tremendous. And he said what he was
able to, and he was willing to say what he meant
to those people around him who meant things
to him. And you don't have to wait until you
have a terminal cancer diagnosis.
Kevin Rose: No, you don't.
Tim Ferriss: You shouldn't wait.
Kevin Rose: Just because it may not be that,
right. It may be a car crash. It may be something
where you don't get the chance to say these
things. And so it's important to do it now.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, you've got
to do it. Great to see you, man.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, good to see you. Happy
New Year. Excited for — this is going to be, oh,
don't you — top me off a little bit at cheers —
Tim Ferriss: Cheers buddy.
Kevin Rose: — to the New Year
and to all the listeners out there, wishing
you a happy and healthy new year. And yeah,
I'm excited to continue this new — I
mean, it's always a new year of change,
a new year of change and exploration. I think
one thing that you and I, let's take a sip.
The one thing that you and I have in common
is just this lifelong pursuit of evolution.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: Of figuring
out — because the secret, that no one will
tell you, is no matter how much money you make,
no matter how much success you have, we're
all still figuring out and in Ram Dass' words,
we're all just walking each other home.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Well said, man. I'm
going to leave it there.
Kevin Rose: Here we go.
Tim Ferriss: Cheers, buddy.
Kevin Rose: Happy New Year.
Tim Ferriss: Happy early New Year, and happy
New Year to everybody listening. And as always,
be just a little kinder than is necessary until
the next episode that applies to other people,
but also applies to yourself. Take
it easy. Take it easy. Life is short,
but life is long, and we're all just figuring
it out. And by the way, as far as I can tell,
you never really figure it out.
Kevin Rose: No, you don't.
Tim Ferriss: So true. So true. CTFO, chill the
fuck out a little bit. Be a little easier on
yourself. And we'll put everything in
the show notes at tim.blog/podcast for
all the stuff we talked about.
Tim Ferriss: Kevinrose.com is
a better website. You can head over there.
Tim Ferriss: Kevinrose.com! Be sure to check
out this amazing new podcast I've heard of.
Kevin Rose: New podcast. Kevinrose.com
is the best place to go. Forget tim.blog.
Tim Ferriss: And KevKev KevKev TalkTalk coming
at you soon. Make sure to listen to everybody.
Kevin Rose: See you.